This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. No matter how many weddings you've been to, it's hard to shake that contagious feeling of optimism. Couples pledge to love one another in sickness and in health, for richer, for poorer. Family members dab tears from their eyes, agreeing that these two people are meant to be together forever. But so many marriages become unhappy.
这里是“隐藏的大脑”。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。无论你参加过多少场婚礼，那种具有感染力的乐观情绪总是难以消除。伴侣们发誓无论生病还是健康、富有还是贫穷，都要相爱到永远。家人们拭去眼角的泪水，一致认为这两个人注定要永远在一起。然而，如此多的婚姻最终却变得并不幸福。
Some dissolve. Some end in divorce. and even the successful ones are not without challenges. No one would deny that long-term relationships are hard, and in fact, there's evidence they're getting harder. Over the past few weeks, our Love 2.0 series has explored new ways to think about how we engage with romantic partners and spouses. We've talked about how to build new bonds with our significant others,
有些婚姻破裂了，以离婚收场，即使是那些成功的婚姻也并非没有挑战。没有人会否认长期关系是艰难的，事实上，有迹象表明它们正变得越来越艰难。在过去的几周里，我们的“爱2.0”系列探讨了思考我们如何与浪漫伴侣和配偶交往的新方式。我们讨论了如何与另一半建立新的纽带，
how to strengthen the bonds we already have. We've looked at how we respond to our partner's most annoying habits and how we can let go of our desire to change them. Today, we bring you a classic episode that many listeners have told us is one of their favorites. It's about the changing nature of marriage in the United States and other parts of the world. Lots of people argue that having these high expectations is problematic
以及如何巩固我们已有的纽带。我们探讨了如何应对伴侣最令人讨厌的习惯，以及如何放下改变他们的渴望。今天，我们为你带来一期经典节目，许多听众告诉我们这是他们最喜欢的节目之一。它讲述了美国以及世界其他地方婚姻性质的变化。许多人认为，抱有如此高的期望是有问题的，
and it's harming the institution of marriage. And frankly, among the people who used to argue that is myself. How our expectations of marriage have evolved and a paradoxical way to achieve more happiness in our relationships this week on Hidden Brain. To understand marriage today,
并且它正在损害婚姻制度。坦白说，曾经持这种观点的人之中就包括我自己。我们对婚姻的期望是如何演变的，以及在我们的关系中实现更多幸福的矛盾方式，本周尽在“隐藏的大脑”。为了理解今天的婚姻，
we thought it best to go back to a time and place when marriage was very different. Well, I've been studying the history of family life for many, many years, but I specifically got interested in marriage as we got into these debates about what traditional marriage was. That's Stephanie Coons. She's an emeritus professor at the Evergreen State College and the author of the book, Marriage, A History, How Love Conquered Marriage.
我们认为最好回到一个婚姻截然不同的时代和地方。嗯，我研究家庭生活的历史已经有很多很多年了，但当我们卷入关于什么是传统婚姻的争论时，我特别对婚姻产生了兴趣。那是斯蒂芬妮·孔茨。她是长青州立大学的名誉教授，也是《婚姻简史：爱是如何征服婚姻的》一书的作者。
I interviewed her back in 2017. Stephanie says the earliest marriages had nothing to do with the feelings of two people or their attraction to one another. As you probably know, marriage was much more about economics and acquiring powerful in-laws. Marriage originally arose in more egalitarian-band-level societies as a way of sharing resources and establishing peaceful relations with groups that you might otherwise only see occasionally and you might not know if they were going to be friends or enemies. It was a way of circulating obligations and goods.
我在2017年采访过她。斯蒂芬妮说，最早的婚姻与两个人的感情或彼此的吸引力毫无关系。正如你可能知道的那样，婚姻更多地关乎经济和获取强有力的姻亲。婚姻最初产生于更具平等主义色彩的部落社会，作为一种共享资源并与那些可能只偶尔见一次面、甚至不知道对方会是朋友还是敌人的人建立和平关系的方式。这是一种流通义务和物资的方式。
I marry my child off to you, and that means you owe me things, but I also owe you things. Stephanie brought up a famous example from history, the union between Cleopatra of Egypt and Mark Anthony of Rome. Elizabeth Taylor as Cleopatra, Siren of the Nile. This is from a 1963 film version. Richard Burton as Mark Anthony. Nash, impetuous leader of once invincible legion, dreaded adversary on the field of battle.
我把我的孩子嫁给你，这意味着你欠我东西，但我也欠你东西。斯蒂芬妮举了一个历史上的著名例子：埃及艳后克丽奥佩特拉与罗马的马克·安东尼的结合。伊丽莎白·泰勒饰演克丽奥佩特拉，尼罗河的妖姬。这是1963年电影版中的画面。理查德·伯顿饰演马克·安东尼。曾经不可战胜的军团中狂野、冲动的领袖，战场上令人畏惧的对手。
The Hollywood version of the story portrays Cleopatra and Antony as being very much in love. But Stephanie paints a slightly different picture. There may have been passion, but it was more passion for power than sexual, although sexual probably entered into it too. Cleopatra and Anthony's marriage was primarily about strategy. Rome and Egypt were the two most powerful empires in the world. So getting them, anybody who got them together and they got an alliance between them would be unstoppable.
好莱坞版本的这个故事把克丽奥佩特拉和安东尼描绘成深陷爱河。但斯蒂芬妮描绘了一幅略有不同的画卷。这里可能存在激情，但这更多是对权力的激情，而不是性欲，尽管性欲可能也牵涉其中。克丽奥佩特拉和安东尼的婚姻主要关乎战略。罗马和埃及是世界上最强大的两个帝国。因此，把它们结合在一起的任何人，只要能在它们之间建立同盟，就将不可阻挡。
The story goes that Cleopatra was married to her brother, and without getting into all the details, let's just say she wasn't too happy with that. So she started an affair with Julius Caesar, the ruler of Rome. Cleopatra became pregnant. When the baby was born, he was named Caesarian. The child gave Cleopatra and Caesar a claim to each other's throne. It was something they both desperately wanted. Sounds like an episode of Game of Thrones, right? Well, then Caesar died, and Mark Anthony came along.
故事说，克丽奥佩特拉嫁给了她的兄弟，抛开所有细节不谈，只能说她对此并不太高兴。于是她开始与罗马统治者尤利乌斯·恺撒有染。克丽奥佩特拉怀孕了。孩子出生后，被取名为恺撒里昂。这个孩子给了克丽奥佩特拉和恺撒对彼此王位的宣称权。这是他们俩都极度渴望的东西。听起来像《权力的游戏》里的情节，对吧？好吧，然后恺撒死了，马克·安东尼出现了。
And, of course, the story tells that she seduced him. But, you know, when you really look at what was happening practically, this was another political alliance. First, as did Caesar, you will marry me according to Egyptian ritual. It's not a conditionless reward. You will declare by your authority, Cesarian to be king of Egypt. and we will rule together in his name. Caesarian was too young to rule,
当然，故事说她勾引了他。但是，你知道，当你真正审视实际发生的事情时，这又是一次政治同盟。首先，正如恺撒所做的那样，你将按照埃及的仪式娶我。这不是无条件的奖赏。你将以你的权威宣布恺撒里昂为埃及国王，我们将以他的名义共同统治。恺撒里昂太小，无法统治，
and Anthony could rule in his place. So it was a great big political alliance, just like Game of Thrones. This marriage strategy wasn't just for kings and queens. There's a common misconception that people of lower classes in this time married for love. Not true, Stephanie says. You couldn't run a farm with one person.
而安东尼可以取代他进行统治。所以这是一个巨大的政治同盟，就像《权力的游戏》一样。这种婚姻策略不仅仅适用于国王和王后。有一个普遍的误解，认为这一时期的下层阶级是为了爱而结婚。并非如此，斯蒂芬妮说。你无法靠一个人经营农场。
You couldn't run a bakery with one person. So people who were bakers married us. bakers. If you were a peasant, you wanted somebody who had a good reputation as a hard worker. And that was much more important than this frivolous luxury is the way it was really thought of as how attracted you were to the person. A different idea started to become more common in the 17 and 1800s. Jane Austen, the famous novelist, may well have been the trailblazer. For those who don't remember the plot of her book, Pride and Prejudice, Mr. Darcy, who has been promised in marriage to his wealthy cousin, falls instead for Elizabeth Bennett, a woman of modest
你无法靠一个人经营面包店。所以面包匠们和面包匠结婚。如果你是一个农夫，你会想要一个有好名声、吃苦耐劳的人。这比这种被真正认为是一种轻浮奢侈的东西——你对这个人的吸引力——要重要得多。一种不同的想法在17和18世纪开始变得更加普遍。著名小说家简·奥斯汀很可能是先驱。对于那些不记得她的书《傲慢与偏见》情节的人来说，本应与富有表妹结婚的达西先生，却爱上了伊丽莎白·班内特，一个出身微寒的女子。
means. That throws his aunt into a rage. Mr. Darcy is engaged to my daughter. Now what of you to say? Only this, if that is the case, you can have no reason to suppose he would make an offer to me. You selfish girl! This union has been planned since their infancy. Do you think it can be prevented by a young woman of inferior birth? Heaven and earth are the shades of Pemberley to be thus polluted. Now tell me once and for all, are you engaged to him? I am not. So Stephanie, talk about this. This is the first glimmers, if you will, of the idea that in some ways love was coming to conquer marriage. This clip you used is perfect because it illustrates the fact that men found it easier to embrace the love match than women did. Men could marry down because they
这让他的姑妈勃然大怒。达西先生已经与我的女儿订婚了。现在你有什么话说？只有这个，如果真是这样，你没有任何理由认为他会向我求婚。你这个自私的女孩！这个联盟从他们婴儿时期起就计划好了。你认为一个出身低微的年轻女子能阻止它吗？天啊，彭伯利的山林竟然要这样被玷污。现在最后回答我一次，你和他订婚了吗？我没有。所以斯蒂芬妮，谈谈这个。如果你愿意的话，这是“爱正在征服婚姻”这一理念的最初曙光。你用的这段剪辑非常完美，因为它说明了这样一个事实：男人比女人更容易接受爱情婚姻。男人可以娶家境不如自己的女性，因为他们
could go out and earn wages. Women had to be very, very, very. very cautious. You know, as you can say, my heart inclines to Harry, but, you know, I'd better marry who my parents want me to and the person who is most likely to be able to support me. And so there was a prolonged period of time where men actually were more romantic than women in the courtship arena. By the second half of the 19th century, the Jane Austen model of marriage had taken firm hold in the United States. The idea of marrying for anything other than love, came to be seen as old-fashioned. And with the rise of this new idea came another. If marriage was once seen as a partnership between people from similar backgrounds and similar social classes,
可以出去挣薪水。女性必须非常、非常、非常谨慎。你知道，正如你所说，我的心倾向于哈利，但是，你知道，我最好还是嫁给父母希望的那个人，嫁给那个最有可能养活我的人。因此，在求爱领域，曾长时期出现男人实际上比女人更浪漫的情况。到了19世纪下半叶，简·奥斯汀式的婚姻模式在美国站稳了脚跟。因任何非爱情原因而结婚的想法，开始被视为老套。随着这一新理念的兴起，另一个理念也随之出现。如果说婚姻曾经被视为背景相似、社会阶层相似的人之间的伙伴关系，
the new model of marriage began to celebrate the coming together of people who were supposedly radically different from one another. And you got this new theory that love was a union of opposites. Now this idea came that men and women were totally different and you could only have access to the emotions, resources, abilities of the other by getting married and staying married. You were incomplete without it. In practice, this dovetailed with a changing economic landscape in the country, where men increasingly became the breadwinners and women became homemakers. The 1950s sitcom, Leave It to Beaver, makes clear this division between male and female roles.
那么新的婚姻模式开始赞美那些被认为彼此截然不同的人的结合。于是你得到了这样一个新理论：爱是两个对立面的结合。现在这个观点认为男人和女人是完全不同的，你只有通过结婚并保持婚姻，才能接触到对方的情感、资源和能力。没有它，你就是不完整的。在实践中，这与该国不断变化的经济格局相吻合，在这个格局中，男性越来越多地成为顶梁柱，而女性则成为家庭主妇。20世纪50年代的情景喜剧《留给海狸》明确指出了这种男女角色的分工。
You know, Dad, it's funny. What's funny? Well, whenever we cook inside, mom always says it cook. But whenever we cook outside, you always do it. How come? Well, it's sort of traditional, I guess. You know, they say a woman's place is in the home, and I suppose as long as she's in the home, she might as well be in the kitchen. Well, that explains about mom, but how come you always do the outside cooking? Well, I'll tell you, son, women do all right when they have all the modern conveniences.
你知道，爸爸，这很有趣。有什么有趣的？嗯，每当我们在里面做饭时，妈妈总是说它煮。但每当我们在外面做饭时，总是你来做。为什么？嗯，我想这算是一种传统吧。你知道，人们说女人的地方在家里，我想只要她在家里，她不妨也在厨房里。好吧，那妈妈的事解释通了，但为什么总是你做户外的烹饪？嗯，我告诉你，儿子，当女性拥有所有现代便利设施时，她们做得很好。
But us men are better at this rugged type of outdoor cooking. Sort of a throwback to caveman days. days. Talk to me about this idea, Stephanie. So clearly, gender biases played a role in how we came to think about marriage. Well, absolutely. But what's interesting about this clip is that the concept of the male breadwinner was unknown before the 19th century. Women worked in the home, but so did men. And men didn't go out and bring home the bacon. Women helped raise the pig. Maybe the man butchered it, but the woman often cured the bacon and took the bacon to market. So again, part of this new idea of love that I talked about earlier. The idea that men and women were so
但我们男人更擅长这种粗犷的户外烹饪。有点像是回到穴居人时代的做法。跟我聊聊这个想法，斯蒂芬妮。很显然，性别偏见在我们如何看待婚姻方面发挥了作用。嗯，绝对是的。但这段剪辑有趣的地方在于，男性顶梁柱的概念在19世纪之前是未曾闻听的。女性在家里工作，但男性也一样。而且男人也不是出去把培根拿回家。女性帮忙养猪。也许男人屠宰它，但女性通常会腌制培根并把培根拿到集市上去卖。所以再次回到我之前谈到的关于爱的这个新理念。这种认为男人和女人是如此
different that the man had to do all the outside stuff because the woman couldn't do it and the woman had to do all the inside stuff because the man couldn't do it and wasn't supposed to do it. The idea of the love match may have been controversial at first, but when concerns were raised about how people from different backgrounds would stay together, when they didn't have the bond of shared work or the larger framework of a shared community, advocates for love marriage said men and women would stay together because they needed one another to feel psychologically complete. This theory was later appropriated in romantic stories and movies. Think of the saying opposites attract. But as the divorce rate in America surged in the 1970s and 80s, many started to think
不同，以至于男人必须做所有的户外事情，因为女人做不了；女人必须做所有的室内事情，因为男人做不了也不应该做。爱情婚姻的想法起初可能是具争议性的，但当人们开始担忧来自不同背景的人如何在缺乏共同工作的纽带或共同社区的更大框架的情况下维持婚姻时，爱情婚姻的倡导者表示，男人和女人会在一起，因为他们需要彼此来获得心理上的完整感。这一理论后来被浪漫故事和电影所借用。想想“异性相吸”这句俗语。但随着美国离婚率在20世纪70年代和80年代飙升，许多人开始认为，
that what you should look for in a mate was not your opposite, but someone who shared your interests and values. It wasn't quite the same as one baker looking to marry another baker, but more along the lines of people marrying others with similar educational backgrounds and similar cultural and political attitudes. You know, it's important to understand that love itself the definition has changed. It's different today than it was at the beginning of the love match when it was a union of opposites. And today, it's really like a union of people who share so many values. And that's one of the big challenges of love today because we spent 100 years trying to get people to see a difference as erotic and the source of love. And now our big challenge is how do we
你在伴侣身上寻找的应该不是你的对立面，而是与你有共同兴趣和价值观的人。这不完全等同于一个面包师想娶另一个面包师，而更像是人们与具有相似教育背景以及相似文化和政治态度的人结婚。你知道，重要的是要理解爱本身，它的定义已经改变了。它今天与爱情婚姻刚开始时、当它还是对立面的结合时有所不同。而今天，它真的就像是一群拥有如此多共同价值观的人的结合。这也是当今爱情的一大挑战，因为我们花了一百年的时间试图让人们将差异视为色情和爱的源泉，而现在我们面临的大如何将
make equality erotic? How do you make equality erotic? Where is the sizzle in consensus and compromise in child care pickups and doctor's appointments in a lifestyle symbolized by a Honda Civic rather than a flashy Ferrari? When we come back, we'll answer that question. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. We've been talking with historians Stephanie Coons about how marriage changed from an institution that was primarily about economic partnerships and political
平等变得色情？你如何让平等充满情趣？共识和妥协、接送孩子和看医生、由本田思域而不是耀眼的法拉利象征的生活方式中，魅力在哪里？当我们回来时，我们将回答这个问题。你正在收听的是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。这里是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。我们一直在与历史学家斯蒂芬妮·孔茨讨论婚姻如何从一个主要关乎经济伙伴关系和政治
experience to one based on romantic love. Once this shift took hold in the United States over the course of the 19th century, love marriages became the norm. Soon, everyone wanted to know the secrets of making love last. You've seen those documentaries and news stories about elderly couples who've managed to stay together for most of their lives. Meet Milt and Leota, sweethearts for life. We've been married six, six. 60 years. 60 beautiful years. When people ask me, how long have you been married? I truthfully say, not long enough. It's just been like yesterday. A heartwarming documentary about the life of a couple that has been together for three quarters of a century, 75 years. There's something that these
经验的机构转变为一个基于浪漫爱情的机构。一旦这种转变在19世纪的美国扎根，爱情婚姻就成了常态。很快，每个人都想知道让爱长久的秘密。你见过那些关于老年夫妇设法厮守一生的纪录片和新闻报道。认识米尔特和利奥塔，一生的甜心。我们已经结婚六、六。60年。60个美丽的年头。当人们问我，你们结婚多久了？我诚实地说，还不够久。感觉就像昨天一样。这是一部关于一对在一起四分之三个世纪、即75年的夫妇生活的温馨纪录片。这些
stories don't tell you. Social psychologist Eli Finkel at Northwestern University has studied the psychological effects of the historical changes that Stephanie has documented. Eli is the author, of the all-or-nothing marriage, how the best marriages work. He has a very dramatic term for the challenge that many couples face today. Modern marriage, he says, runs the risk of suffocation. To understand that term, Eli says you have to look at yet another shift that started in the 1960s and 70s. We wanted to complement our emphasis on love, achieving love through marriage,
故事并没有告诉你一些事情。西北大学的社会心理学家伊利·芬克尔研究了斯蒂芬妮所记录的历史变化的心理影响。伊利是《全或无婚姻：最好的婚姻是如何运作的》一书的作者。对于许多伴侣今天面临的挑战，他有一个非常戏剧化的词。他说，现代婚姻面临着窒息的风险。为了理解这个词，伊利说你必须看看始于20世纪60年代和70年代的又一次转变。我们希望通过强调个人成长的方式，来实现获得个人成就感的新重点，
with a new emphasis on achieving a sense of personal fulfillment in the way of personal growth. So in the terminology of psychology, we wanted to self-actualize through our marriage. We wanted to grow into a more authentic version of ourselves. One example of this comes from the best-selling book by Elizabeth Gilbert about walking out on her husband and trying to create a more meaningful life for herself.
来补充我们对爱的强调，即通过婚姻实现爱。因此，用心理学的术语来说，我们希望通过我们的婚姻实现自我实现。我们希望成长为更真实的自己。这方面的一个例子来自伊丽莎白·吉尔伯特的畅销书，讲述了她离开丈夫并试图为自己创造更有意义的生活。
We're going to play a few clips from the movies as we chat. And this one comes from the movie Eat, Pray, Love, featuring Julia Roberts. we'd only bought this house a year ago hadn't I wanted this I had actively participated in every moment of the creation of this life so why didn't I see myself in any of it
在聊天时，我们将播放几段电影剪辑。这一段来自由朱莉娅·罗伯茨主演的电影《美食、祈祷和恋爱》。我们才刚买这所房子一年不是我想要这个吗我曾积极参与了这个生活创造的每一个时刻为什么我在其中任何一个时刻都看不到自己
the only thing more impossible than staying was leaving it sounds like she was searching for her true self Eli. Yeah, that's exactly right. She in some sense helps to epitomize both the strengths and the weaknesses of this modern contemporary approach to marriage where we're looking to our spouse, again, not only for love, but also this sense of personal growth and fulfillment. And for the first time, you start to see cases where people would say, as I think Liz Gilbert would say, that she was in a loving marriage and
唯一比留下更不可能的事就是离开。听起来她一直在寻找真正的自己，伊利。是的，完全正确。在某种程度上，她有助于体现这种现代当代婚姻方法的优势和劣势，在这种方法中，我们不仅向配偶寻求爱，还寻求这种个人成长和成就感。并且你第一次开始看到这样的情况：人们会说，我想莉斯·吉尔伯特会说，她身处一段充满爱的婚姻中，
he was a good man and treated her well, but she felt stagnant, and she really wasn't willing to endure a stagnant life for the next 30 or 40 years, and she walked out. This would have been unthinkable, of course, a hundred years ago, let alone 500 years ago. Yes. This would have been a very, very bizarre thing to say, and marriage, you know, it wasn't really until the 70s that you started seeing no-fault divorce laws. It used to be that you had to prove some type of serious mistreatment, like abuse or desertion. Yes, so it's a very modern idea that we are entitled to a sense of real fulfillment and personal growth through the marriage. And if our marriage is falling short, many of us consider it to be a reasonable option to end the marriage for that alone.
他是一个好人并且对她很好，但她感到停滞不前，她真的不愿意在接下来的30或40年里忍受停滞不前的生活，于是她离开了。当然，这在一百年前是不可想象的，更不用说五百年前了。是的。这会是一件非常非常奇怪的事情，而且婚姻，你知道，直到70年代你才真正开始看到无过错离婚法。过去你必须证明某种严重的虐待，比如虐待或遗弃。是的，所以这是一个非常现代的想法，即我们有权通过婚姻获得真正的成就感和个人成长。如果我们的婚姻达不到要求，我们中的许多人会认为仅凭这一点就结束婚姻是一个合理的选择。
You come up with what I think of as a riff on a very famous psychological concept. Many years ago, Abraham Maslow proposed that human beings have a series of different needs that begin with physical security and end with a search for meaning and fulfillment. And you say that a similar hierarchy has come to describe how many Americans think about marriage. Tell me about what you call Mount Maslow. Well, one of the most exciting things that happened to me in the process of writing the book is I learned a lot about the history and the sociology and the economics of marriage, particularly reading people like Stephanie Coontz, because my primary expertise is as pretty much a laboratory psychologist. I bring couples into the laboratory and I videotape them interacting and I follow them over time. But these other disciplines, scholars in these other disciplines, adopt a different approach. So I realized that marriage had, in fact, changed radically in terms of the way we expect it to fulfill our needs in America, that is.
你提出了一个我认为是对一个非常著名的心理学概念的改编的想法。许多年前，亚伯拉罕·马斯洛提出人类有一系列不同的需求，从身体安全开始，到寻找意义和成就感结束。你说类似的层级结构已经用来描述许多美国人如何看待婚姻。跟我讲讲你所说的“马斯洛山”。嗯，在写这本书的过程中，发生在我身上最令人兴奋的事情之一是，我了解了很多关于婚姻的历史、社会学和经济学知识，尤其是阅读了像斯蒂芬妮·孔茨这样的人的作品，因为我的主要专业是实验室心理学家。我把伴侣带进实验室，录下他们互动的视频，并随着时间推移跟踪他们。但这些其他学科的学者采用了不同的方法。所以我意识到，就我们期望它满足我们在美国的的需求的方式而言，婚姻实际上已经发生了根本性的改变。
And it used to be that marriage was about basic economic survival. We've seen that from Stephanie Kuntz and others. And you can think of that as being at the bottom of Maslow's hierarchy toward the physiological and safety needs, really survival-based needs. And then as we track marriage and it becomes more about love, now we're more toward the middle of Maslow's hierarchy. And then in the 1960s and then really up until today, we're in this new era where, yes, we're still looking for love, but now we're toward the top of Maslow's hierarchy, where he's talking about things like esteem and self-actualization. And so our expectations of marriage have basically ascended from the bottom to the top of Maslow's hierarchy over the course of American history. And one of the ideas that emerged, as I was writing this book, is that we can conceptualize Maslow's hierarchy not just in terms of a triangle, but in terms of a mountain, right? And the advantage of thinking of Maslow's hierarchy as a mountain in this way is that it brings to mind a number of metaphors related to mountaineering.
过去，婚姻关乎基本的经济生存。我们从斯蒂芬妮·孔茨和其他人那里看到了这一点。你可以认为这处于马斯洛需求层次的底部，朝向生理和安全需求，真正基于生存的需求。然后，随着我们追踪婚姻，它变得更多地关乎爱，现在我们更接近马斯洛需求层次的中间。然后在20世纪60年代，一直到今天，我们进入了一个新时代，是的，我们仍然在寻找爱，但现在我们处于马斯洛需求层次的顶部，他谈到了诸如尊重和自我实现之类的事情。因此，在美利坚历史的进程中，我们对婚姻的期望基本从马斯洛需求层次的底部上升到了顶部。在我写这本书时出现的一个想法是，我们可以不仅从三角形的角度，而且从山峰的角度来概念化马斯洛的需求层次，对吧？以这种方式将马斯洛的需求层次视为一座山的优势在于，它让人联想到许多与登山有关的比喻。
And one thing that we know when we climb up a big mountain is the views get increasingly gorgeous as you get to the top. But the oxygen gets a little thinner. And so having a successful experience way up there at the top requires that you are able to invest a lot of oxygen, either bring extra oxygen with you on the mountain or invest a lot of time and energy in the marriage to succeed up there. So to continue your analogy, if we want to get to the top of Mount Maslow, but we have failed to bring our oxygen tanks with us, that's what leads, presumably, to what you call the suffocation model. That's right. That's right. That is, it's lovely way up there at the top.
我们知道的一件事是，当我们爬上一座大山时，当你到达山顶时，景色变得越来越壮丽。但氧气变得有点稀薄。因此，在山顶拥有一次成功的体验需要你能够投入大量的氧气，要么在山上随身携带额外的氧气，要么在婚姻中投入大量的时间和精力以便在那里取得成功。因此，延续你的比喻，如果我们想登上马斯洛山的山顶，却没有带上我们的氧气瓶，这大概就会导致你所说的“窒息模型”。没错。没错。也就是说，在山顶风景优美，
And if we're looking to try to achieve not only this sense of love and connection, but also this sense of personal growth and authenticity through the marriage, but we're trying to do it on the cheap. And that disconnect is what I'm talking about when I talk about the suffocation of marriage. What I love about that analogy is it makes physical almost, this psychological process, process, this effect of our expectations. All of us can imagine what it would be like to suddenly wake up one morning and decide, you know, I'm going to run a marathon or I'm going to climb a mountain, a very tall mountain, without really any preparation. And we would recognize that it's not just
如果我们正试图通过婚姻不仅实现这种爱和连结感，还实现这种个人成长和真实感，但我们却试图以微小的代价来做到这一点。这种脱节就是我在谈论婚姻的窒息时所指的。我喜欢这个比喻的地方在于，它几乎将这个心理过程、将我们的期望所产生的这种效应变得形体化。我们所有人都可以想象，如果有一天早晨醒来突然决定，你知道我要去跑马拉松，或者我要去爬一座山，一座非常高的山，却没有做任何准备，那会是什么样子。我们会认识到这不仅
difficult to do, but potentially foolhardy. That is exactly right. I think if we think about what we're really asking of our marriages these days in terms of the, you know, ambition of these expectations, then we realize that if we're too tired or lazy to invest in the quality of the relationship, that of course we're not going to be able to make the summit attempt. Of course we're not going to be able to succeed in meeting those expectations toward the very high end of Maslow's hierarchy. And so the book talks a lot about how we can, in fact, align what we're asking of the marriage with what the marriage is realistically able to offer us. So there have been a few people, Eli, over the years, who've tried to explore the same ideas that you have.
做起来困难，而且可能极其鲁莽。完全正确就我们期望的雄心壮志而言，如果我们思考这些天我们对婚姻的真正要求，那么我们就会意识到，如果我们太累或太懒，不愿投资于关系的质量，那么我们当然无法尝试登顶。当然，我们无法成功满足马斯洛需求层次最高端的那种期望。因此，这本书讨论了许多关于我们如何实际上将我们对婚姻的要求与婚姻实际能够提供给我们的现实相调和的方法。伊利，这些年来有一些人试图探索和你相同的想法。
Esther Perel, of course, comes to mind. In her famous TED Talk, she summarizes some of these challenges, and I want to play your short clip. So we come to one person, and we basically are asking them to give us what once an entire village used to provide. Give me belonging, give me identity, give me continuity, but give me transcendence and mystery and all in one. Give me comfort, give me edge, give me novelty, give me familiarity, give me predictability, give me surprise. And we think it's a given, and toys and lingerie are going to save us with that. So I love that passage, Eli, but you talk about the same idea in your book. You give the analogy of a woman who once turned to five different friends for important things she needed.
埃丝特·佩瑞尔当然会浮现在脑海中。在她著名的TED演讲中，她总结了其中一些挑战，我想播放你的一小段剪辑。所以我们来到一个人面前，我们基本上是在要求他们给我们曾经由整个村庄提供的东西。给我归属感，给我身份认同，给我延续性，但同时也要给我超越感和神秘感，集所有这些于一身。给我舒适，给我刺激，给我新鲜感，给我熟悉感，给我可预测性，给我惊喜。我们认为这是理所当然的，而玩具和内衣将拯救我们。我喜欢那段话，伊利，但你在书中谈到了相同的想法。你打了个比方，一个女人曾经向五个不同的朋友寻求她需要的重要事情。
But once she gets married, she turns to our husband for those same five things, and he's not able to provide all of them, and she feels now unfulfilled. That's right. In the research literature on how we achieve our goals, there's a clunky word called multifanality. And this is the idea that a given means can serve multiple goals. So, for example, when I walk to work, that might simultaneously meet my need to get to work, but also my needs to get some fresh air and get some exercise. And so this one activity can serve all sorts of functions. What's interesting is that's really what we've done to marriage, right?
但一旦她结婚了，她就会向我们的丈夫寻求这五样东西，而他无法提供所有这些，她现在感到无法满足。没错。在关于我们如何实现目标的研究文献中，有一个笨拙的词叫做“多重功能性”。这就是一个既定手段可以服务于多个目标的想法。例如，当我步行去上班时，这可能同时满足我去上班的需求，但也满足了我呼吸新鲜空气和进行一些锻炼的需求。所以这一个活动可以服务于各种各样的功能。有趣的是，这确实是我们对婚姻所做的事情，对吧？
is that marriage for a long time served a set and relatively limited array of different functions for us. And over time, we've piled more and more of these emotional and psychological functions. So instead of turning to our close friends and other relatives for nights out on the town, for deep, intimate disclosure, to a larger and larger extent, our spouse has replaced a lot of what we used to look to our broader social network to help us do. You know, as I read your book, Eli, I realize that it's not just what we expect from our partners that's changing. We also now expect that we can unlock special things in our partners. And this is also reflected in the movies. The 1997 movie, as good as it gets, has a scene where a woman who is fed up with, you know, put downs by her, by the man who's trying to woo her, demands that he give her a compliment.
也就是说，很长一段时间以来，婚姻为我们服务于一组相对有限的各种功能。随着时间的推移，我们堆积了越来越多的这些情感和心理功能。因此，我们不再向密友和其他亲戚寻求夜出游玩、进行深度的亲密倾诉，而是在越来越大的程度上，我们的配偶取代了许多我们过去依赖更广泛的社交网络来帮助我们做的事情。你知道，当我读你的书时，伊利，我意识到不仅我们对伴侣的期望在改变。我们现在还期望我们能够在伴侣身上解锁特殊的东西。这也在电影中得到了反映。1997年的电影《尽善尽美》中有一个场景，一个受够了她试图追求她的男人的贬低的女人，要求他给她一个赞美。
Okay. Here I go. Clearly a mistake. I've got this, what, ailment? My doctor, a shrink that I used to go to all the time. He says that in 50 or 60% of the cases, a pill really helps. I hate pills.
好吧。我来了。显然是个错误。我有这个，什么，病？我的医生，我以前常去的心理医生。他说，在50%或60%的情况下，药丸真的很有帮助。我讨厌药丸。
My compliment is that night when you came over and told me, that you would never... Um... Alright, well, you were there, you know what you said. Well, my compliment to you is... The next morning, I started taking the pills. I don't quite get how that's a compliment for me. You make me want to be a better man.
我的赞美是那天晚上你过来告诉我，你永远不会……嗯……好吧，你在那儿，你知道你说了什么。好吧，我给你的赞美是……第二天早上，我开始吃药。我不太明白这怎么能算对我的赞美。你让我想要成为一个更好的男人。
That's maybe the best compliment of my life. I found this so revealing in the context of your book, Eli. Helen Hunt's character is telling Jack Nicholson's character that the thing that makes her feel really good is not what he does for her, but what she can do to unlock something special in him. Yeah, he is smitten with her And his desire for her, his being impressed with her and the desire to make her like him more actually makes him want to grow into a better person.
这也许是我一生中最好的赞美。在你的书的语境中，我发现这太有启示意义了，伊利。海伦·亨特饰演的角色告诉杰克·尼科尔森饰演的角色，真正让她感觉很好的不是他对她做了什么，而是她能做些什么来激发他身上一些特别的东西。是的，他对她神魂颠倒，他对她的渴望、对她的印象深刻以及让她更喜欢他的愿望，实际上让他想要成长为一个更好的人。
And in some sense, that's the absolute archetype of what we see in contemporary marriage today. We're looking for our spouse to bring out the ideal version of us, the latent version that's inside of us that we can hopefully grow into with enough time and effort. You have a wonderful term in your book. You call this the Michelangelo effect. Yeah, this is a term I actually got from my doctoral advisor, Carol Rusbold. Many of your listeners will know that Michelangelo, when he talked about the sculpting process, talked not in terms of revealing a sculpture, but in terms of unleashing it from the rock in which it's been slumbering. So the sculptor's job is not to create something new, but merely to refine and buff and polish and maybe scrape away the rough edges of what was already nesting within the rock. That's a really good
从某种意义上说，这就是我们在当今当代婚姻中所看到的绝对原型。我们希望我们的配偶能够激发出我们理想的版本，即我们内心深处潜藏的版本，如果有足够的时间和努力，我们有望成长为那个版本。你的书里有一个绝妙的词。你称之为“米开朗基罗效应”。是的，这个词我实际上是从我的博士导师卡罗尔·鲁斯博德那里学来的。你的许多听众会知道，米开朗基罗在谈论雕刻过程时，不是用揭开雕塑来谈论的，而是用从它一直沉睡的岩石中释放它来谈论的。所以雕刻师的工作不是创造新的东西，而仅仅是精炼、打磨、抛光，或许刮掉已经筑巢在岩石之中的粗糙边缘。这真的是一个很好的
metaphor for how partners today try to relate to each other. That is, all of us have an actual self, the person that we currently are, but we also have an ideal self, a version of ourselves that's aspirational. Like, what could I maybe become if I could be the best version of myself? And we look to our partners to be our sculptors, to help us until we actually grow to toward the best ideal version of ourselves. So, Eli, do we actually have this power, this power to play sculptor and bring out the best in someone else? The answer is yes.
比喻，关于今天的伴侣如何试图彼此相处。也就是说，我们所有人都有一个真实的自我，即我们目前的这个人，但我们也有一个理想的自我，一个有抱负的自己的版本。就像，如果我能成为最好的自己，我可能会变成什么样？我们指望我们的伴侣成为我们的雕刻师，帮助我们，直到我们真正成长为最好的理想版本的自己。所以，伊利，我们真的有这种力量吗，这种扮演雕刻师并激发出别人最好一面的力量？答案是肯定的。
We do have this power, but it's not easy to do, and not everybody is compatible. And sometimes the version of you that you want to grow into isn't the version of you that I want you to grow into. And this is a very delicate dance. that we play. And, you know, the best relationships today, the sorts of relationships that I call the all relationships and the idea of the all or nothing marriage, they're well aligned in this sense. They're able to bring out the best in each other and connect in a way that facilitate
我们确实有这种力量，但这并不容易做到，而且并非所有人都是兼容的。有时你想成长为的那个版本，并不是我想要你成长为的那个版本。这是一支非常微妙的舞。我们跳着。你知道，当今最好的关系，我称之为“全”关系的那种关系以及“全或无婚姻”的理念，在这方面是高度契合的。他们能够激发出彼此最好的一面，并以一种促进
each other's personal growth and therefore helps to produce a really profound amount of emotional connection and psychological fulfillment. You know, many marriage experts say that high expectations are the enemy of happiness in marriage, you come to a slightly different conclusion. You say that it's true that on average many marriages might be unhappier today than they were half a century ago, but that isn't true of all marriages. Who are the exceptions? The exceptions are people who bring those expectations and are able to meet them. And this is, I think, the crux of the entire issue. Lots of people argue that having these high expectations is problematic and it's harming the institution of marriage.
彼此个人成长的方式进行连结，从而有助于产生真正深厚的情感连结和心理成就感。你知道，许多婚姻专家说，高期望是婚姻中幸福的敌人，你得出了一个略有不同的结论。你说，诚然，平均而言，今天的许多婚姻可能比半个世纪前更不幸福，但这并不适用于所有婚姻。例外是谁？例外是那些抱有这些期望并能够实现它们的人。我认为，这才是整个问题的核心。许多人认为抱有这些高期望是有问题的，并且它正在损害婚姻制度。
And frankly, among the people who used to argue that is myself. I, when I set out to write this book, thought I was writing a book about the decline over time in marriage and how we're throwing more and more expectations on this one institution and this one relationship, but we're not investing enough time. And therefore, we've really created a seriously problematic approach to marriage. And it wasn't until I reviewed these other scientific literatures and learned more about how things have changed,
坦白说，曾经持这种观点的人之中就包括我自己。当我着手写这本书时，我以为我写的是一本关于婚姻随着时间推移而衰落的书，以及我们如何在这个单一的制度和单一的关系上施加越来越多的期望，但我们没有投入足够的时间。因此，我们确实创造了一种严重有问题的婚姻方法。直到我回顾了这些其他的科学文献并更多地了解了事情是如何变化的，
that I realized that's really half the story. It is true that we are asking a lot more, especially when it comes to these more psychological and love-based needs than we did in the past. But some marriages are able to meet those needs. And so what does it mean if you have a marriage that you're looking for to meet these very highest-level needs, say, for example, in Maslow's hierarchy, and the marriage succeeds in doing so? You're able to achieve a level of fulfillment in the marriage that would have been out of reach
我才意识到这其实只是一半的故事。的确，我们在提出更多的要求，尤其是在这些更加心理化和基于爱的需求方面，比过去更多。但一些婚姻能够满足这些需求。因此，如果你拥有一段你所期望的能够满足这些最高级别需求的婚姻，比如马斯洛需求层次中的需求，并且婚姻成功做到了这一点，这意味着什么？你能够在婚姻中实现一种在这样一个时代里是遥不可及的成就感，
in an era where we really weren't even trying to meet those types of needs. So at the same time that these high expectations are waiting us down and making it more difficult to achieve a healthy marriage, at the same time that a marriage that would have been acceptable to us in 1950 is a disappointment to us today because of these high expectations, those same expectations have placed within reach a level of marital fulfillment that was out of reach until pretty recently. So this idea that some people invest heavily in their marriages, at the expense of careers and friends, maybe even, you know, their children's activities, you say this is perfectly captured in a scene from another movie.
在那个时代，我们甚至没有真正尝试去满足这些类型的需求。因此，在这些高期望压垮我们并使实现健康婚姻变得更加困难的同时，在1950年本可让我们接受的婚姻在今天因为这些高期望而令我们感到失望的同时，这些同样的期望也将一种直到不久前还遥不可及的婚姻成就感置于我们触手可及的地方。因此，这种认为有些人为了事业和朋友甚至可能是为了孩子的活动而在婚姻中大量投入的想法，你说这在一部电影的场景中得到了完美的捕捉。
In Sideways, Paul Jammadi's wine connoisseur character explains to his love interest the difference between a Pino and a Cabernet. Why are you so into Pino? I mean, it's like a thing with you. I don't know. I don't know. Um, it's a hard grape to grow, as you know, right? It's, uh, it's thin skin temper metal ripens early. It's, you know, it's not a survivor like Cabernet, which can just grow anywhere and, uh, thrive even when it's neglected. No, Pino needs constant care and attention, you know, and in fact, it can only grow in these Really specific little tucked-away corners of the world.
在《杯酒人生》中，保罗·吉亚玛提饰演的葡萄酒鉴赏家向他的心上人解释黑皮诺和赤霞珠的区别。为什么你这么喜欢黑皮诺？我的意思是，这就像是你的一个标志。我不知道。我不知道。嗯，它是一种很难种植的葡萄，你知道的，对吧？它，呃，它的皮很薄，性格敏感，成熟得早。它，你知道，它不像赤霞珠那样是个生存能手，赤霞珠可以在任何地方生长，即使被忽视也能茁壮成长。不，黑皮诺需要持续的关怀和注意，你知道，事实上，它只能在世界上这些真正独特的小角落里生长。
And only the most patient and nurturing of growers can do it, really. Only somebody really takes the time to understand Pino's potential can then coax it into its fullest expression. Then, I mean, oh, it's flavor. They're just the most haunting and brilliant and thrilling and subtle and ancient on the planet. So, of course, Eli, when we hear this and we're thinking about this in the context of marriage, why wouldn't we all want to grow Pino? Well, I think a lot of us should be pretty careful about Pino.
而且只有最有耐心和滋养力的种植者才能真正做到这一点。只有真正花时间了解黑皮诺潜力的人，才能随后诱导它发挥出最充分的表现。然后，我的意思是，哦，它的风味。它们简直是地球上最令人难忘、最辉煌、最惊艳、最微妙且最古老的。所以，当然，伊利，当我们听到这个并在婚姻的语境中思考这一点时，为什么我们大家不都想种植黑皮诺呢？嗯，我认为我们中的许多人应该对黑皮诺非常小心。
I mean, I think that clip does an absolutely masterful job of providing an analogy to how marriage has changed in America in the last, say, 50 years. years or more. It's changed from an institution approximating Cabernet, which can just grow anywhere and thrive even when it's neglected, to a much more delicate, fragile institution that requires a lot of tending and maintenance. So you ask me, who would ever want anything other than Pinot Noir, at least according to how Miles thinks about those grapes? And I would say a whole lot of people might not want to deal with something that fragile and delicate. But like he says those of us who get it right that is well and he's he's talking about the grapes when there's the right grower and the right context the flavors are just haunting and brilliant
我的意思是，我认为那段剪辑在提供一个类比方面做得非常出色，这个类比关于美国婚姻在过去50年左右的时间里是如何发生变化的。年或更长时间。它已经从一个类似于赤霞珠的机构——赤霞珠可以在任何地方生长，甚至在被忽视时也能茁壮成长——变成了一个更加娇嫩、脆弱的机构，需要大量的照料和维护。所以你问我，除了迈尔斯对那些葡萄的看法之外，谁会想要黑皮诺以外的东西？我会说，一大群人可能不想处理如此脆弱和娇嫩的东西。但正如他所说，那些做对的人，也就是说，当有正确的种植者和正确的背景时，风味简直是令人难忘、辉煌、
and subtle and ancient and what i think he's saying is this is a high-maintenance grape it takes a lot of work and if you aren't careful and attentive you're going to be disappointed in it it's going to fail you but if you work hard enough you can have something truly exquisite and that is where we are today with the all-or-nothing marriage. One of the conclusions of your book is that we have, in some ways, two major alternatives when it comes to dealing with this challenge that many of us want to be at the top of Mount Maslow but are not investing the time and effort or the patients to actually get there. In your own marriage, you describe a trip to Seattle where
微妙而古老，我认为他想说的是，这是一种高维护成本的葡萄，它需要大量的工作，如果你不小心和专注，你会对它感到失望，它会让你失望，但如果你足够努力，你就能拥有真正精致的东西。这就是我们今天面临的全或无婚姻的现状。你的书的结论之一是，在某种程度上，当我们面对许多人想要登上马斯洛山顶却又没有投入时间和努力或耐性去真正到达那里的挑战时，我们有两个主要的选择。在你的婚姻中，你描述了一次西雅图之行
in your own analogy, you found yourself starved of oxygen. That's right. We went through a hard time. I in particular went through a hard time with the adjustment to parenthood. And I, frankly, I think that the reason I had a hard time is the sort of stuff that I'm talking about in the book. I hadn't sufficiently calibrated or recalibrated my expectations to what life would be like with a newborn. And the research on this is, in fact, tricky. Obviously, having a, you know, a bundle of joy is a wonderful thing. And you love the new baby like crazy and kissing that little fuzzy head is one of the most satisfying things we ever get to do in our lives. But the reality is a recent estimate suggests that it's about 33 and a half additional hours a week of extra time, like of care that goes into that.
用你自己的比喻来说，你发现自己严重缺氧。没错。我们经历了一段艰难的时期。尤其是，我在适应为人父母的过程中经历了一段艰难的时期。坦白说，我认为我之所以过得艰难，正是因为我在书中谈论的那些事情。我没有充分地调整或重新调整我对新生儿生活会是什么样子的期望。事实上，关于这一点的研究很复杂。显然，拥有一个快乐的结晶是一件美妙的事。你会疯狂地爱上这个新生宝宝，亲吻那个毛茸茸的小脑袋是我们一生中最满足的事情之一。但现实是，最近的一项估计表明，照顾孩子每周大约需要额外增加33个半小时。
And I would ask the couples out there listening who don't have a kid, where would those 33.5? hours a week come from. And then you're complimenting that with with some sleep deprivation and frankly much less time for emotional connection or sexual connection with your spouse. And is it any surprise that the research evidence shows that the arrival of the first baby tends to be pretty hard on the quality of the relationship, on the marital satisfaction, for example. And it was during that period where we took a trip to Seattle to see my closest and longest, longest term friend, one of these life experiences that has always been a source of bliss and joy for me throughout the, you know, 30-some-eyed years of my life at the time.
我想问问那些没有孩子的听众伴侣们，每周这33.5个小时是从哪里来的呢？然后，你还要面对睡眠不足的问题，坦白说，与配偶进行情感连接或亲密连接的时间也少了很多。研究证据表明，第一个孩子的降临往往会对伴侣关系的质量（例如婚姻满意度）造成不小的冲击，这难道还令人意外吗？正是在那段时期，我们去西雅图探望了我认识最久、最深交的朋友。这是我生命中的经历之一，在我当时三十多年的岁月中，它一直是我的快乐和幸福之源。
And I was miserable. It turns out that traveling across the country with an eight-month-old is not anything like traveling across the country without an eight-month-old. And then you're together with your best friend, and there's all the stuff that you used to do. But now there's an eight-month-old there, and you're not doing any of those things. And I, I, you're, really had a hard time. I mean, I can't really exaggerate this. I really struggled emotionally with the adjustment. And I said to my wife, and I regret saying this, it's hard for me to say out loud right now, you know, I can endure this. Like, I can get past this and I certainly love my daughter, but I need to stop trying to have fun because if I'm trying to enjoy my life
而我却痛苦不堪。事实证明，带着一个八个月大的孩子跨国旅行，跟不带八个月大的孩子跨国旅行完全是两码事。然后，你和最好的朋友聚在一起，你们以前会做各种各样的事情。但现在那里有个八个月大的孩子，你们什么也做不了。我真的、真的过得很艰难。我的意思是，我真的无法夸大这一点。在适应的过程中，我在情感上真的挣扎得很痛苦。我对妻子说——我后悔说了这话，现在让我大声说出来也很不容易——你知道的，我能忍受这一切。比如，我能熬过去，而且我也绝对爱我的女儿，但我需要停止试图去寻找快乐，因为如果我试图享受生活
and I'm trying to enjoy you, I keep end up disappointed. And she was very upset about that. And And, you know, I made her cry. I'm not proud of this at all. But she cried and thought, what, is this the end of us trying to live a good life together? Are we just going to hunker down and be unhappy together? But the truth is this ended up being the lowest point, but also the starting of where I started to recover a little bit. It took that moment before I started to get serious about making life better again. And one of the major ways I did it was by recalibrating my expectations, yes, but also reinvest.
并且试图享受有你的陪伴，我最终总是会感到失望。她对此感到非常难过。而且，你知道的，我把她惹哭了。我一点也不以此为骄傲。但她哭了，心想，难道这就是我们努力共同过上美好生活的终点吗？难道我们就要这样死守在一起，然后一起不快乐地生活吗？但事实是，这最终成了最低谷的时刻，却也是我开始逐渐恢复的起点。正是经历了那一刻，我才开始认真地让生活重回正轨。我采取的主要方法之一是重新调整我的期望，是的，但同时也是重新投入。
in a way that made sure that I was more connected to my wife than we had been, and it took some work. And it did require that we lower expectations in some ways and then try to meet those lowered expectations. And we were, in fact, able to do it, but it certainly wasn't easy. Eli and other researchers have found that it's not especially easy to fulfill a partner's emotional and psychological needs when you're struggling to pay the bills or working three jobs. This might be one reason that the institution of marriage appears to be especially fragile among low-income couples. When we come back, we're going to look at tangible solutions.
以一种确保我与妻子的联系比以往更紧密的方式，这确实需要付出一些努力。它确实要求我们在某些方面降低期望，然后努力去满足这些降低后的期望。事实上，我们做到了，但这绝对不容易。伊利和其他研究人员发现，当你连账单都难以支付或身兼三职时，要去满足伴侣的情感和心理需求并不是一件特别容易的事。这或许就是为什么低收入夫妻之间的婚姻制度显得格外脆弱的原因之一。稍后回来，我们将探讨切实可行的解决方案。
If you can't afford to take your partner on that romantic trip to Paris, but you still want to get to the top of Mount Maslow, we'll show you how to get there. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. On today's show, marriage.
如果你负担不起带伴侣去巴黎进行浪漫之旅的费用，但你仍然想登上马斯洛山的山顶，我们会告诉你如何做到这一点。您正在收听的是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。今天的节目主题是：婚姻。
Marriage is what brings us together today. That's right. Marriage. Marriage, that blessed arrangement, that dream. within a dream. The priest from that iconic scene in the princess bride
婚姻是今天将我们聚在一起的纽带。没错。婚姻。婚姻，那受祝福的安排，那幻梦中的幻梦。来自电影《公主新娘》中那个标志性场景的神父
describes it best. Or does he? We're taking a look at how marriage has evolved over time. It went from a partnership of necessity to a union of two very different people who need one another's love to be complete. Now it's gone to the all-or-nothing relationships identified by psychologist Eli Finkel.
对它做了最好的描述。真的是这样吗？我们正在探讨婚姻是如何随着时间演变的。它从一种出于必需的伙伴关系，演变成了一个由两个极需彼此之爱才能圆满的截然不同的人组成的结合体。而现在，它已经变成了心理学家伊利·芬克尔所指出的“全或无”的关系。
Eli argues that our ex-execkel. Expectations for marriage, both gay and straight, among rich and poor, have dramatically increased. Couples who are able to meet these higher expectations are happier than couples have ever been. But couples who fall short are unhappier than their counterparts a century ago. If you have follow-up questions or thoughts about these ideas, and you'd be willing to share them with the hidden brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone. Then email it to us at Ideas at Hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, marriage.
伊利认为，无论同性还是异性恋人，无论贫穷还是富有，我们对婚姻的期望都急剧上升。能够满足这些更高期望的夫妻比以往任何时候都更幸福。但那些达不到要求的夫妻，却比一个世纪前的同龄人更加不幸。如果你对这些观点有后续疑问或想法，并且愿意与“隐藏的大脑”听众分享，请在手机上录制一条语音备忘录。然后将其通过电子邮件发送给我们：Ideas at Hiddenbrain.org。邮件主题请填写：婚姻。
That email address again is Ideas at Hiddenbrain.org. Eli says there are things we can do, what he calls love hacks, to reorient how we think about marriage, and make ourselves more fulfilled in long-term relationships. Some of your listeners might be fans of Marcel Proust, who argues that mystery is not about traveling to new places, but about looking with new eyes. And the love hacks are exactly that. There are ways that we can try to experience the same relationship, but view it in a different way
再次重复该邮箱地址是：Ideas at Hiddenbrain.org。伊利说，我们可以采取一些他称之为“爱情秘诀”的方法，来重新调整我们对婚姻的看法，让我们在长期关系中获得更多成就感。你们中的某些听众可能是马塞尔·普鲁斯特的粉丝，他认为奥秘不在于前往新的地方，而在于用新的眼光去观察。而这些爱情秘诀正是如此。它们是一些方法，让我们能够尝试体验相同的关系，但以不同的方式看待它，
and therefore be a little bit happier in the relationship itself. So psychologists have long talked about something called the fundamental attribution era, which is sometimes when we see someone behave in a way that we don't like, there's two ways to interpret it. You can either say this person is behaving badly because they're a bad person, or you can say this person's behaving badly because there's something in the context. There's something happening around him or her that's causing him or her to behave this way. And one of the hacks that you suggest is to reinterpret negative behavior from your partner in a way that's more sympathetic rather than critical. Right. And I'm not saying it's magic. I'm not saying it's the easiest thing to do, but I'm saying that with some effort we can get a little better at this. So your spouse is late. Your spouse is disrespectful. I mean, ideally not in a huge way. But your spouse does.
从而在关系本身中感到稍微幸福一点。因此，心理学家长期以来一直在谈论一个叫做“基本归因谬误”的概念，即有时当我们看到某人的行为不符合我们的喜好时，有两种解释方式。你可以说这个人表现不好是因为他是个坏人，或者你可以说这个人表现不好是因为情境中有某种因素。他或她周围发生了某些事情，导致他或她做出这种行为。你建议的秘诀之一，就是以一种更具同情心而不是批判性的方式来重新诠释伴侣的负面行为。没错。我并不是说这是魔术。我并不是说这是最容易做到的事情，但我的意思是，通过一些努力，我们可以把这一点做得更好一些。所以，你的配偶迟到了。你的配偶很不尊重人。我的意思是，理想情况下不是以一种非常严重的方式。但你的配偶做了
does something inconsiderate, you have a lot of control over how that behavior affects you. And in particular, you have control over whether you want to explain that behavior in terms of something about your spouse that's maybe stable and a character, a logical assessment. Like, my spouse is always such a jerk. You can try instead to say, look, my spouse was a jerk just now, but he's under a lot of stress at work. Or you can think, look, he probably tried the best he could. there was probably some traffic or some crisis at work, I'm just going to let it ride.
一些考虑不周的事情，你对这种行为如何影响你有很大的控制权。特别是，你可以控制自己是否想要这样解释这种行为：将其归咎于你配偶身上某种可能比较稳定且性格化的、逻辑上的评估。比如，我的配偶总是这么混蛋。相反，你可以试着这样想：听着，我的配偶刚才确实是个混蛋，但他工作压力很大。或者你可以这样想：听着，他可能已经尽力了，可能遇到了一些交通堵塞或工作上的危机，我还是算了吧。
Now, I'm not saying these are easy things to do because we do have a default to explain other people's behaviors as elements of their character. But the fact is, and we should be better at understanding this, there are all sorts of things that contribute to why somebody engaged in one behavior over another behavior. And we have some control over the extent to which we interpret our partners inconsiderate or rude behavior in a way that's more generous and kind, and the kinder approach will make us happier in the relationship, and our partner will probably be happier too. You also think that having what you call a growth mindset is a useful thing. What do you mean by that? So the psychologist Carol Dweck at Stanford, she's developed this idea that people differ
现在，我并不是说这些事情很容易做到，因为我们确实有一种默认倾向，把别人的行为解释为他们性格中的固有元素。但事实是，我们也应该更好地理解这一点——有各种各样的因素共同决定了为什么某人会做出某种行为而不是另一种行为。我们有一定的主动权，可以决定在多大程度上以更宽容、更善良的方式去诠释伴侣考虑不周或粗鲁的行为，而这种更善良的方法会让我们在关系中更幸福，我们的伙伴可能也会更幸福。你也认为拥有所谓的“成长型思维”是一件很有用的事。你这话是什么意思？斯坦福大学的心理学家卡罗尔·德维克提出了这样一个观点：人们的看法因人而异
in terms of how they think about various attributes. So she studies intelligence, for example. People differ in the extent to which they think intelligence is something that's fixed and stable and you have it or you don't, versus it's malleable and it's something that you can develop over time. Well, it turns out there's a lot of good research now on the extent to which people feel like compatibility in a relationship is something that is fixed. You could call this a destiny mindset, people who think, look, partners are either compatible or they're not, and that's the end of the story, versus more of a growth-oriented mindset who think, look, there's a lot of room where you can develop compatibility. And in fact, going through difficulties in a relationship isn't a signal that, oh, my goodness, we're incompatible people. It's an opportunity to learn to understand each other better and strengthen the relationship through the resolution of the conflict. And here again, it's not like we have complete control over the thoughts that we have about these things, but we can try to make ourselves adopt a more constructive, growth-oriented,
在如何看待各种特质方面。例如，她研究智力。人们在多大程度上认为智力是固定且稳定的——你生来就有或者没有——还是认为它是可塑的、可以随时间发展的，这因人而异。好吧，事实证明，现在有很多优秀的研究表明，人们在多大程度上觉得关系中的契合度是固定不变的。你可以称之为“宿命论思维”——那些认为“看吧，伴侣要么契合，要么不契合，这就是全部”的人；而与之相对的则是更具成长导向的思维，他们认为“看吧，你们有很多空间可以去培养契合度”。事实上，经历关系中的困难并不是在发出信号，天哪，我们是不相容的人。这是一个通过解决冲突来更好地了解彼此并巩固关系的机会。在这里，同样地，并不是说我们能完全控制自己对这些事情的想法，但我们可以努力让自己采取更具建设性、成长导向的
to thinking about conflict in the relationship rather than a more destiny-oriented approach that can often view conflict as a deep sign of incompatibility, and that's pretty destructive for the relationship. You also talk about more serious alternatives. So if people find, over time, that they are just incompatible with one another, and yet they have these high expectations of different things they want from their life. You suggest that one of the alternatives might be to develop systems where people are actually getting different things from different people. That's right. It's the same logic again, right? So we have this all or nothing approach. We expect these high level things. And many of our marriages are, in fact, falling short of that. So one possibility is that we try to invest more in the relationship. And the second possibility, which we've called love hacks, is how to be more efficient. But the third possibility, and I actually think we should be pretty serious about this. There's nothing shameful about making these sorts of sacrifices. We should ask less. In what ways can we,
方式来看待关系中的冲突，而不是采取那种通常会将冲突视为深层不契合标志的宿命论方法，这对关系来说往往是极具破坏性的。你还谈到了更严肃的替代方案。因此，如果人们随着时间推移发现彼此确实不合，然而他们对生活又有各种各样的巨大期望。你建议其中一种替代方案可能是建立这样一种系统：人们实际上从不同的人身上获取不同的东西。没错。这依然是相同的逻辑，对吧？所以我们采用了这种“全或无”的方法。我们期待这些高水平的东西。而且事实上，我们的许多婚姻都未能达到这一标准。因此，一种可能性是我们试图在关系中投入更多；第二种可能性，也就是我们所说的爱情秘诀，是如何变得更高效；但第三种可能性，我实际上认为我们应该非常严肃地对待它。做出这种牺牲并没有什么可耻的。我们应该减少索取。在哪些方面，我们可以在
in our own marriage, look to the relationship and see, man, like, I have been looking to fulfill this sort of need in the relationship for a long time, and I'm chronically a little disappointed about how we do as a couple and helping to fulfill this sort of need. Is there some other way that I might be able to meet this need I have, either through some other friends or even on my own? And there's some research by the psychologist Elaine Chung that looks at what she calls social diversification. Like can you diversify your social portfolio, if you will? And she looks at the people we turn to when we're feeling emotions that can help us regulate those emotions. So
我们自己的婚姻中审视这段关系，然后心想：天哪，我长期以来一直期望在婚姻中满足这种需求，但作为一个伴侣，我们在帮助满足这种需求方面表现得有些不尽如人意，我对此常常感到有点失望。有没有其他方法可以满足我的这种需求，无论是通过其他朋友还是靠我自己的力量？心理学家伊莱恩·钟做了一些研究，探讨了她所谓的“社交多元化”。就像你可以让你的社交资产组合多样化一样，如果你愿意的话？她研究了当我们经历情绪时会向谁求助，以此来帮助我们调节这些情绪。所以
to whom do you turn when you're feeling sad? To whom do you turn when you want to celebrate your happiness? And she assesses how much people look to a relatively small number of people to do all of those things versus a larger number of people. And she finds across a range of studies now that people who've diversified their social portfolio, that is, turned to different sorts of people for different sorts of emotional experiences, tend to be a little bit happier. And so with regard to marriage in particular, we've really lumped a lot of our emotional fulfillment on this one relationship. And for many of us, we would benefit and our marriage would actually benefit if we asked a little bit less in some respects.
当你感到悲伤时，你会向谁倾诉？当你想要庆祝快乐时，你会向谁求助？她评估了人们是向极少数人寻求所有这些事情，还是向更多的人寻求。现在，她在多项研究中发现，那些实现了社交多元化的人，也就是说，向不同类型的人寻求不同类型的情感体验的人，往往会稍微快乐一点。因此，特别就婚姻而言，我们确实把大量的情感寄托在这单一的关系上。对我们许多人来说，如果我们能在某些方面稍微减少一点期望，我们自己会受益，我们的婚姻实际上也会受益。
I love the idea of diversification and the analogy with financial diversification. I mean, so the idea, of course, is that you might have, you know, bonds in your portfolio, and they don't do very well, and they don't grow a lot, but they're very stable. And then you might have some stocks in your portfolio that, you know, are high growth, but they also have the potential for losing a lot. And what you're suggesting is that by having different things accomplish different parts of what you need, your portfolio as a whole ends up being more stable than if you put all your eggs in one basket. You know, that's right. And that's a neat way of thinking about it that I hadn't fully processed
我很喜欢多元化的这个想法，以及它与金融多元化的类比。我的意思是，这个想法当然是，你可能在你的资产组合中有一些债券，它们的表现不是很好，增长也不多，但它们非常稳定。然后你可能在资产组合中有一些股票，你知道的，它们增长潜力大，但也有可能损失惨重。而你的建议是，通过让不同的事物来完成你所需的不同部分，你的整体资产组合最终会比把所有鸡蛋放在一个篮子里更加稳定。你知道的，这没错。这是一种巧妙的思考方式，我以前并没有完全消化过
previously. In some sense, what we're doing with marriage these days is we've got a heavily stock-loaded portfolio. And that means that when the market is up, we make huge gains. But that's a lot of eggs to put in that one basket. And when the market goes down, we're going to get hit pretty hard. And to some degree, that's also a reasonable. metaphor for the self-expressive marriage, where we look to one person to fulfill so many of our emotional and our psychological needs, the payoff can be huge, but there's a lot of risk. Now, for people to actually consider diversifying their portfolio romantically and emotionally, presumably this also creates stresses on what we think of as marriage. So if people are looking
这一点。从某种意义上说，我们如今对待婚姻的方式是，我们持有一个重仓股票的资产组合。这意味着当市场上涨时，我们获得巨大的收益。但这等于把太多的鸡蛋放在了同一个篮子里。而当市场下跌时，我们会遭受相当惨重的打击。在某种程度上，这也是自我表达型婚姻的一个合理的隐喻。我们寄希望于一个人来满足我们众多的情感和心理需求，回报可能是巨大的，但也伴随着巨大的风险。现在，如果人们真的考虑在浪漫和情感上实现资产组合的多样化，这大概也会给我们所认为的婚姻带来压力。因此，如果人们在婚姻之外寻找
outside the marriage for emotional support or other needs, some people are going to say, well, are you really married anymore? I think this is a valid question, and this is a complexity that comes up when you think about how an institution like marriage changes over time. I suspect that if somebody transported from 1750 to today, they might look around and say,
情感支持或其他需求，有些人就会说，嗯，你们真的还算结婚吗？我认为这是一个有效的问题，而且当你思考像婚姻这样的制度如何随时间变化时，就会出现这种复杂性。我猜，如果有人从1750年穿越到现在，他们可能会环顾四周并说：
whoa, that doesn't look like marriage. I don't even really get what you guys are doing. Or better yet, if we transported back to 1750 and looked at what people were expecting and how little they were looking for personal fulfillment from the marriage, we would be bewildered. So one of the more controversial ideas that I play with in the book
哇，那看起来可不像是结婚。我甚至搞不懂你们在搞什么名堂。或者更好的是，如果我们穿越回1750年，看看人们当时的期望是什么，看看他们从婚姻中寻求的个人满足感是多么微乎其少，我们会感到迷惑不解。因此，我在书中探讨的一个更具争议性的想法
is when I'm talking about ways that we can ask less of the marriage, by the way, when I am doing that, I'm talking about how can we strengthen the marriage by asking less of it? One of the places that I consider is in the romantic or sexual domain. So is it reasonable for some people to consider some type of consensual non-monogamy. Now, this is not cheating. That's the whole idea of consensual non-monogamy. This is an understanding that we don't need to have complete monogamy all the time. And you can negotiate an alternative. In fact, among millennials, this is becoming an
是，当我谈论我们可以对婚姻减少诉求的方法时——顺便说一句，当我这么做的时候，我讨论的是我们如何通过对婚姻减少诉求来巩固婚姻。我考虑的领域之一是浪漫或性爱领域。那么，某些人考虑某种形式的知情同意下的非一夫一妻制，这合理吗？现在，这不是出轨。这正是知情同意下的非一夫一妻制的全部意义所在。这是一种共识，即我们不需要永远保持完全的一夫一妻制。你可以协商出另一种选择。事实上，在千禧一代中，这正在成为一种
increasingly common way of thinking about the ideal relationship. So this is an ideal option, especially for people who generally are connecting pretty well and they love each other and their good co-CEOs of the household together, but they're really struggling to sustain a mutually satisfying sex life together. Those are particularly good opportunities to consider, could we reduce some of the disappointment and pressure by opening up the relationship in some ways that we can both agree to? It's certainly a high-risk option,
越来越普遍的理想关系思考方式。因此，这是一个理想的选择，特别是对于那些总体上相处得相当不错、彼此相爱、并且是优秀的家庭联合首席执行官，但却在维持彼此满意的性生活方面苦苦挣扎的伴侣。这些是考虑以下问题的绝佳机会：我们能否通过以双方都能同意的某些方式开放关系，来减少一些失望和压力？这无疑是一个高风险的选择，
but it's an option that probably will benefit some relationships. You see that you and your wife, Allison, have developed a shorthand of sorts for the times you want to communicate affection, but are starved of time. And it has to do with this song. The majesty's a pretty nice girl, but she doesn't have a lot to say. My majesty's a pretty nice girl, but she changes from day to day. I want to tell her that I love her a lot, but I got her got a belly full of her. that's Paul McCartney at the end of the Abbey Road medley. It's like a little 23-second bonus track. And it's interesting. I haven't heard it in a while. And even as I listened to it, as you just
但它很可能会让某些关系受益。你发现你和你的妻子艾莉森发明了一种简写方式，用于在你想表达爱意但又极度缺乏时间的时候。这和这首歌有关。我的女王是个相当不错的女孩，但她没有什么话要说。我的女王是个相当不错的女孩，但她天天都在变。我想告诉她我很爱她，但我对她已经腻烦透顶了。那是保罗·麦卡特尼在《阿比路》串烧歌曲结尾处唱的。这就像是一首短短23秒的隐藏曲目。很有意思。我已经很久没听过了。甚至当我听着它，正如你刚才
played it, I sort of teared up a little bit because it's been a very significant song for my wife and me in our marriage. When we were first dating, you know, people are falling in love and they often say, I love you or whatever. But I was very partial to this idea of bellyful of wine, right? I want to tell her that I love her a lot, but I got to get a belly full of wine. And eventually saying belly full of wine was our little replacement for, I love you. And what was neat about the way we used the phrase belly full of wine is it was able to contain like a whole terabyte of information about love and respect and affection in this like one second phrase. We could turn to each other and just say belly full of wine and just really communicate so
播放的那样，我还是有点热泪盈眶，因为这首歌对我和我妻子在我们的婚姻中具有非常重要的意义。当我们刚开始约会时，你知道的，人们坠入爱河，经常会说“我爱你”之类的话。但我非常偏爱“腻烦透顶”这个想法，对吧？我想告诉她我很爱她，但我对她已经腻烦透顶了。最终，说“腻烦透顶”成了我们对“我爱你”的小小替代品。我们使用“腻烦透顶”这个短语的妙处在于，它能够在这个短短一秒钟的短语中，容纳关于爱、尊重和 affection（爱意）整整一个太字节的信息。我们可以转向彼此，只说一句“腻烦透顶”，就能在那个极短的瞬间、仅仅通过这几个词，真正传达出如此
much information in that very little, just those few words. And this is an example of a broader idea that we don't appreciate enough, which is that every marriage has its own culture, that has its own language and its own expectations. And we can leverage the features of how culture works to benefit the marriage with a sort of emotional shorthand that can help express affection. And it can be especially crucial if you're going through a difficult time and maybe things are getting a little hot, and maybe you're on the verge of a fight, and you can say, hey, baby, belly, belly full of wine, and you might be able to diffuse some of what could have been a pretty problematic episode.
多的信息。这是一个更广泛理念的例子，而我们对此的认识还远远不够，那就是：每一段婚姻都有其自身的文化，拥有它自己的语言和期望。我们可以利用文化运作特征的优势，通过某种能够帮助表达爱意的情感简写来使婚姻受益。如果你正经历一段艰难的时期，事情可能有点剑拔弩张，你可能处于争吵的边缘，而你可以说：“嘿，宝贝，腻烦透顶，”你也许就能化解一些本可能演变成相当棘手事件的冲突。
Eli Finkel is a social psychologist at Northwestern University. He is the author of the all-or-nothing marriage, how the best marriages work. Eli, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. Do you have a personal story to share about a long-term relationship in your own life that has gone very well or gone very badly? If you'd be willing to share the story with the Hidden Brain audience, or if you have follow-up questions, thoughts, or comments about this episode, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty. Then email the file to us at Ideas at Hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, marriage. That email address again, is Ideas at Hiddenbrain.org. After the break, your questions answered.
伊利·芬克尔是西北大学的社会心理学家。他是《全或无婚姻：最好的婚姻是如何运作的》一书的作者。伊利，非常感谢你今天来到“隐藏的大脑”。非常感谢邀请我。你有没有什么个人故事可以分享，关于你生活中一段非常成功或非常失败的长期关系？如果你愿意与“隐藏的大脑”听众分享这个故事，或者你对本期节目有后续的问题、想法或评论，请找一个非常安静的房间，在你的手机上录制一条语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。然后将该文件通过电子邮件发送给我们：Ideas at Hiddenbrain.org。邮件主题请填写：婚姻。再次重复该邮箱地址是：Ideas at Hiddenbrain.org。休息过后，我们将为您解答疑问。
Psychologist Jonathan Adler returns to the show. He'll answer listeners' questions about the stories we tell about our lives, and we'll hear remarkable tales from listeners about how they came to terms with dramatic and difficult moments in their lives. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. The first films in history were quite simple.
心理学家乔纳森·阿德勒重返节目。他将回答听众关于我们讲述自己生活故事的提问，我们将聆听听众们讲述他们如何释怀生活中戏剧性和艰难时刻的精彩故事。您正在收听的是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。历史上最早的电影非常简单。
A series of moving pictures showed a horse running, a family playing in a garden, and a boxer punching his opponent. As the technology developed, so did the complexity of the stories portrayed on screen. In the 1902 film, A Trip to the Moon, Georges depicted astronomers who fly to the moon,
一系列动态画面展示了一匹奔跑的马、一个在花园里玩耍的家庭，以及一个拳击手击打对手。随着技术的发展，银幕上所讲述故事的复杂性也在增加。在1902年的电影《月球旅行记》中，乔治描绘了飞往月球的天文学家，
get captured by aliens, and then escape back to Earth. As Hollywood evolved into its studio era, the plots of films coalesced into a distinct style with the beginning, middle, and end.
他们被外星人俘虏，然后又逃回了地球。随着好莱坞演变为制片厂时代，电影的情节融合成了一种具有起承转合的独特风格。
In most blockbuster movies today, the characters inevitably reach a satisfying conclusion. Filmmakers with an artistic bent have experimented with different storytelling devices. The 1950 film, Rushamon, is about a samurai who gets murdered. It tells the same story from four perspectives. They end up being four completely different stories. The film Memento tells its plot in reverse, while Inception evokes the feeling of a fragmented dream.
在如今的大多数大片中，角色不可避免地会迎来一个令人满意的结局。具有艺术倾向的电影制作人尝试了各种不同的叙事手法。1950年的电影《罗生门》讲述了一个武士被谋杀的故事。它从四个视角讲述了同一个故事。结果变成了四个截然不同的故事。电影《记忆碎片》倒叙了其情节，而《盗梦空间》则唤起了一种碎片化梦境的感觉。
Jesus. Mind telling your subconscious to take it easy? My subconscious. Remember, I can't control it. When we watch these films, we're riveted by the characters, the action, and the dialogue. But we often fail to notice that the way the story is told has a fundamental impact on how we feel. If Forrest Gump didn't have flashbacks, it would simply be a guy sitting on a bench talking to a stranger. If Star Wars had started with Luke blowing up the Dead Star, it would be a completely different story. What is true in fiction is true in real life as well. How we tell stories, including the stories of our own lives, has profound consequences for our well-being.
天哪。介意告诉你的潜意识放轻松点吗？我的潜意识？记住，我控制不了它。当我们观看这些电影时，我们被角色、动作和对话深深吸引。但我们往往没有注意到，故事的讲述方式对我们的感受有着根本性的影响。如果《阿甘正传》没有闪回，它就只是一个坐在长椅上跟陌生人说话的人。如果《星球大战》是从卢克炸毁死星开始的，那将是一个完全不同的故事。小说中如此，现实生活中亦是如此。我们如何讲述故事，包括我们自己生活的故事，对我们的幸福感有着深远的影响。
Whom we include, whom we exclude, and what point of view we take, all these choices alter how we feel about ourselves and the world. We explored the science of stories and what's known as narrative psychology in a recent episode of Hidden Brain titled U2.0, Change Your Story, Change Your Life. Our guest was Jonathan Adler, a psychologist at Olin College. Today, Jonathan returns to answer listeners' questions about personal stories and how they shape our lives. Jonathan Adler, welcome back to Hidden Brain. Oh, thank you so much for having me. Jonathan, we're constantly telling ourselves stories, and even small details are important
我们包括了谁，我们排除了谁，我们采取了什么观点，所有这些选择都改变了我们对自己和世界的感受。我们在最近一期名为《于2.0，改变你的故事，改变你的人生》的“隐藏的大脑”节目中，探讨了故事的科学以及所谓的叙事心理学。我们的嘉宾是欧林学院的心理学家乔纳森·阿德勒。今天，乔纳森重返节目，回答听众关于个人故事以及它们如何塑造我们生活的提问。乔纳森·阿德勒，欢迎再次来到“隐藏的大脑”。哦，非常感谢邀请我。乔纳森，我们一直在给自己讲故事，甚至连细节也很重要，
in weaving the narrative of who we are. I'm going to start by having you tell me the story of your day today. What happened since you woke up? Well, this morning I got up. I helped my kids get off to school. They are in fifth and seventh grade, so they are navigating their own autonomy and what they're in charge of, but also attending to the clock. And, And then I came here to campus, and I had a little bit of time to get some work done. I met with my new first-year advisees over lunch to get them oriented, and then I came here to the sound studio to get ready to talk with you. I have to confess that one reason we ask people this question sometimes is to establish
在编织我们是谁的叙事时。我先请你给我讲讲你今天这一天的故事。自从你醒来后都发生了什么？嗯，今天早上我起床了。我帮孩子们去上学。他们正上五年级和七年级，所以他们正在摸索自己的自主权以及他们负责的事情，但同时也要注意时间。然后，然后我来到了校园，我有一小段时间可以处理一些工作。我在午餐时间与我新带的一年级新生指导学生见面，让他们熟悉情况，然后我来到了这个录音室，准备和你谈话。我必须坦白，我们有时会问人们这个问题的一个原因是为了建立
audio levels and to make sure they're sounding good. But in the context of this conversation I'm having with you, Jonathan, can you just articulate for a moment why the stories we tell about our own lives are so important? Sure. That story, I don't know, meets any kind of criterion for interesting or important story. And in fact, when we look back over our lives, it's often the big moments that stick around. But the story that I just told you is really all chronology. There's not much more to it than that. But stories actually play a huge number of roles in our lives at the level of the individual, the level of the interpersonal relationship, but also at the broad cultural level. So in my field, we're especially focused on the ways stories provide us with a sense of unity and meaning. So stories integrate us. They make us feel like we're the same person across time and across situations. And they help turn the messy flow of life into something meaningful. But stories are also a vital tool for connection with other people and with
音频电平，并确保他们的声音效果良好。但在我与你进行的这段对话的语境中，乔纳森，你能否简单阐述一下，为什么我们关于自己生活的叙事如此重要？当然。那个故事，我不知道，它是否符合任何有趣或重要故事的标准。事实上，当我们回首往事时，往往是那些重大时刻留存了下来。但我刚才对你讲的故事全都是按时间顺序来的。除此之外没有太多内容了。但在个人层面、人际关系层面，甚至在广泛的文化层面上，故事实际上在我们的生活中扮演着极其大量的角色。因此在我的领域，我们尤其关注故事为我们提供统一感和意义感的方式。所以故事将我们整合在一起。它们让我们觉得自己在跨越时间和各种情境时都是同一个人。它们有助于将纷乱的生活洪流转化为有意义的东西。但故事也是与他人及社区建立联系的重要工具，
communities. And stories play a huge role in both maintaining and changing culture. One of your main findings is that the way we tell stories can be just as important as the content of our stories. For example, there's a lot of significance in where we start our stories and where we end our stories. You call these the chapter breaks in our stories? Yeah. Yeah, it's important to remember that we have two roles to play with respect to our life story. We are both the main character, but we're also the narrator. So while we only have so much control over the things that happened to us, we have somewhat more control over how we parse those experiences. And shifting the chapter breaks of our lives means reframing the beginnings and
并且故事在维护和改变文化方面都扮演着巨大的角色。你的主要发现之一是，我们讲述故事的方式可以和故事的内容一样重要。例如，我们故事的起点和终点具有极大的重要性。你将这些称为我们故事中的“章节断点”？对。是的，重要的是要记住，在对待我们的人生故事时，我们有两个角色要扮演。我们既是主角，但我们也是旁白者。因此，虽然我们对发生在我们身上的事情只有有限的控制权，但对于我们如何剖析这些经历，我们拥有更多的控制权。转变我们生活的章节断点意味着重新构架我们经历的起点和
endings of our experiences. So while we're living our lives, it's hard to know whether we're towards the beginning of some experience versus towards the end of it. But in retrospect, we can sort of make some decisions about how to chunk our lives into episodes and simply moving the beginning or ending of episodes can really recast its meaning. You describe two kinds of stories that you call contamination stories and redemption stories. And both these stories have to do with how we are arranging the chapter breaks of our lives. Can you explain what these two are, perhaps with some examples, Jonathan? Sure. And these are two of many themes that show up in people's stories.
终点。因此，当我们过着自己的生活时，很难知道我们是处于某段经历的初期还是末期。但事后看来，我们可以对如何将生活划分成各个片段做出一些决定，而仅仅移动片段的起点或终点就可以真正重塑其意义。你描述了两种你称之为“污染故事”和“救赎故事”的故事。这两个故事都与我们如何安排生活的章节断点有关。乔纳森，你能解释一下这两者是什么吗，或许可以举几个例子？当然。这些是人们故事中出现的众多主题之二。
Contamination stories are simply good turns bad. And redemption is bad. turns good. So, you know, all lives have good and bad in them. But these themes are very much about where we draw connections and parse the chapter breaks. For example, in the story that I shared with you the last time we talked, it was a story about my experience in college, in studying abroad, and then going into graduate school. And things had been challenging for quite a while. and I really threw myself into my academic work looking towards graduate school. And then when I applied to graduate schools, I only got into one of the programs that I had applied to. And at the time, that felt like a big letdown.
污染故事就是好事变坏了。而救赎则是坏事。变好了。所以，你知道的，所有的生活都有好有坏。但这些主题非常关乎我们在哪里建立联系并划分章节断点。例如，在我上次和你交谈时分享的故事中，那是一个关于我在大学、出国留学，然后进入研究生院的经历的故事。情况已经充满挑战好一阵子了。我真的全身心投入到学业中，期待着研究生院。然后当我申请研究生院时，我只被我申请的项目中的一个录取了。当时，这感觉像是一个巨大的打击。
Now, when I look back from a vantage point 20 years later, it's one of the most important turning points in my life. I really found my intellectual passion. I worked with a graduate mentor who really nurtured my career. I met the person who I went on to marry and have children with. So at the time, I might have cut that experience into a contamination experience where I was working really hard and it didn't turn out. But when I move the ending of that story later and incorporate what came afterwards when I started graduate school, the chapter, the transition from college into graduate school
现在，当我从20年后的视角回首时，它是我生命中最重大的转折点之一。我真正找到了自己的学术激情。我遇到了一位真正培育我职业生涯的研究生导师。我遇到了后来与之结婚并生儿育女的人。所以当时，我可能会把那段经历切成一个污染经历，因为我非常努力却没有好结果。但当我把那个故事的结局往后移，并融入后来我开始读研究生之后的事情时，从大学到研究生院的这个章节、这个过渡，
actually turns out to be this redemptive story where my one option turned out to be a fantastic pathway for me. The striking thing, of course, here is that the facts of your story are not necessarily changing. It's just where you choose to start and where you choose to stop the story.
实际上变成了一个救赎的故事，我唯一的选择结果成了我一条绝佳的道路。当然，这里最引人注目的是，你故事的事实不一定在改变。改变的只是你选择从哪里开始以及选择在哪里结束这个故事。
That's right. And actually, even the emotional experience isn't changing, right? Things were hard and later things were better, but I could cut up the same exact sequence of not only sort of objective chronological facts, but also the emotions associated with them. And I could cut up that story into ways that would render it with different thematic arcs.
没错。事实上，连情感体验也没有改变，对吧？事情曾经很艰难，后来事情变好了，但我可以把完全相同的顺序切碎——不仅是那种客观的时间顺序事实，还有与之相关的情感。我可以把那个故事切成不同的方式，从而呈现出不同的主题弧线。
And there's real consequences for that. We know from the research that contamination themes in people's stories tend to be associated with worse well-being, and redemption tends to be associated with positive well-being. Jonathan, I want to walk you through a story from a listener named Cassandra. here's the first part of her story. It was in 2005 Thanksgiving weekend, and I was with my family in our home in Texas and most of us were asleep in bed around midnight
这会产生真实的后果。我们从研究中得知，人们故事中的污染主题往往与更糟糕的幸福感相关，而救赎往往与积极的幸福感相关。乔纳森，我想带你了解一位名叫卡桑德拉的听众的故事。这是她故事的第一部分。那是2005年的感恩节周末，我和家人在德克萨斯州的家中，午夜时分，我们大部分人都已经在床上睡着了。
when someone came into my garage, planted an explosive device, and blew my house up. We were sleeping, but not my daughter, my teenage daughter. She was upstairs sewing. The lights went off, and then she saw a flame shoot from our driveway across our U-shaped house to the opposite property and she she ran down the stairs
这时有人潜入我的车库，安放了一个爆炸装置，把我的房子炸毁了。我们在睡觉，但我的女儿没有，我十几岁的女儿。她当时在楼上缝纫。灯灭了，接着她看到一道火光从我们的车道穿过我们U字形的房子射向对面的房产，她跑下楼梯
to wake me and my husband up and she said fire fire she screamed she woke us both up i tried to turn my light on but the power was off and i couldn't understand why the light wouldn't turn on the house was covered in black smoke my husband and i wound up running across the end of the bed and we slammed into each other i knocked him out i ran out the bedroom door i met my daughter I met my daughters at the bottom of the stairs. We ran toward the front door. My younger daughter reached over my shoulder to touch the door. And you know, if you don't open a door and feed the fire,
去叫醒我和我丈夫。她说：“着火了，着火了。”她尖叫着把我们两个都吵醒了。我试图开灯，但停电了，我不明白为什么灯打不开。房子里弥漫着黑烟。我和丈夫最终从床尾跑过去，撞在了一起。我把他撞昏了。我跑出卧室门，在楼梯底部遇到了女儿。
and I was thinking, stop, drop, and I didn't even get the word rollout before the door exploded inwards. It knocked me onto my back. My dog jumped over my prone body. Both of my daughters were now out chasing the dog, and my garage door had exploded, and it was metal, And shards of the door were whizzing towards their heads like sawblades. And I thought, they're going to be decapitated.
我遇到了我的女儿们。我们朝前门跑去。小女儿越过我的肩膀去摸门。你知道的，如果你不打开门并给火提供氧气，我当时在想，趴下、掩护、滚动，我甚至还没把“滚动”这个词说出口，门就向内爆炸了。它把我撞翻在地。我的狗从我趴着的身体上跳了过去。我的两个女儿现在都跑出去追狗了。我的车库门已经炸飞了，那是金属的，门碎片像圆锯片一样朝她们的头部呼啸飞去。我想，她们要被斩首了。
So Jonathan, there's more to the story, but what are you hearing so far? Whoa. Thank you, Cassandra, for being willing to share that story. And I'm so sorry that happened to you. This is a highly dramatic moment. And it's certainly setting up the dramatic tension. I'm dying to know what happens next. So I think it's fair to say, Jonathan, that at this point in the story, Cassandra's story is pretty horrific.
所以，乔纳森，故事还有后续，但你目前听到了什么？哇。卡桑德拉，谢谢你愿意分享这个故事。我非常遗憾这种事发生在你的身上。这是一个高度戏剧化的时刻。它无疑正在建立戏剧性的张力。我渴望知道接下来会发生什么。所以我想可以这样说，乔纳森，在故事的这个阶段，卡桑德拉的故事相当可怕。
No one would actually want to be in Cassandra's shoes. This is definitely almost a contamination story because it started out with everyone sleeping peacefully at night and suddenly there's this terrible thing that happens to them. So let me play you the rest of Cassandra's story. It picks up from here. And I thought, they're going to be decapitated. And luckily those sawblades went around them, by them, over them and they were untouched. And I could barely see anything because the next explosion just
实际上没有人愿意身处卡桑德拉的境地。这绝对几乎是一个污染故事，因为它的开端是每个人都在夜里安详地入睡，突然间发生了这件可怕的事情。所以我放给你听卡桑德拉故事的其余部分。它从这里开始。我想，她们要被斩首了。幸运的是，那些圆锯片绕过了她们、从她们身旁掠过、从她们头顶飞过，她们毫发无伤。我几乎什么也看不见，因为下一次爆炸差点
about blinded me and it blew up my ear drums. But I could barely see someone charging through the neighbor's fences pulling on his pants. It was my neighbor, Jeff. He grabbed my dog. He grabbed my daughter and he hustled him into his house. Then I picked myself up and then I glanced down the street and I could see through my near blindness the Christmas lights of red and blue lights coming towards me. Those were fire trucks. Three hours later, 40 of my neighbors were standing with my whole family and my dog in the street outside my house, watching my house burn to the ground. And one of the neighbors got out his best scotch and they passed it around. And somebody else got me some herbal tea. Somebody else gave me a bathrobe. Now I neglected to say that my husband
把我闪瞎，而且炸破了我的耳膜。但我隐约看到有人冲过邻居的栅栏，提着裤子。那是我的邻居杰夫。他抓住了我的狗。他抓住了我的女儿，把他们急忙拉进他的房子里。然后我爬起来，接着我朝街上看去，在几近失明的情况下，我看到红蓝相间的圣诞灯光朝我驶来。那是消防车。三个小时后，40个邻居和我的全家人以及我的狗一起站在我家门外的街道上，看着我的房子烧成平地。其中一个邻居拿出了他最好的苏格兰威士忌，大家传着喝。另一个人给我拿了一些草药茶。另一个人给了我一件浴袍。现在我漏说了一件事，那就是我丈夫
was naked when he was sleeping and when he came to, and I don't know when that was, and came out of the house, he went and grabbed a bathrobe. And I looked up to this two-story house and fire was coming out every window like giant orange eyelashes. And there was my husband standing with his back to me, warming his cockles by the fire at the front door, and he was putting on his bathrobe and tying the silk scash around his waist. It was one of the funniest things I've ever seen. So anyway, as we watched the fire, we saw all the explosions. Somebody invited me into the house, our neighbors. We've all recovered. We all are okay. And we're better for it. Thank you.
当他醒来和苏醒过来时是赤身裸体的，我不知道那是什么时候，从房子里出来时，他去拿了一件浴袍。我抬头看着这座两层楼的房子，大火从每一个窗户里喷涌而出，就像巨大的橙色睫毛。接着我的丈夫背对着我站着，在前门借着火光取暖，他正穿着浴袍，把丝质腰带系在腰间。这是我见过的最搞笑的事情之一。所以不管怎样，当我们看着火灾时，我们看到了所有的爆炸。有人邀请我进屋，是我们的邻居。我们都已经恢复了。我们都很好。而且我们因此变得更好了。谢谢。
Jonathan, this is an amazing story. Talk about the turn that she makes here. It sure is an amazing story, and I'm glad that everyone turned out okay. It's kind of remarkable to be able to find any humor amidst this, let alone the poetry of the Christmas lights being the first responders on their way. Yeah, I mean, Cassandra certainly ends this story
乔纳森，这是一个惊人的故事。谈谈她在这里做出的转折。这确实是一个惊人的故事，我很高兴每个人最后都安然无恙。在一片混乱中能够找到任何幽默感，这实在是相当了不起，更不用说那些作为急救人员的圣诞彩灯所带有的诗意了。是的，我的意思是，卡桑德拉在这个故事的结尾
with a redemptive turn, right? It all turned out okay, and she says at the end were even better as a result. So that is quite something to be able to see that kind of turnaround in the wake of such a dramatic and terrible event. Talk a little bit more about the effects of redemption stories on our well-being, Jonathan. So the research demonstrates over and over that when we're able to take negative experiences and find something redemptive in them, that that tends to be good for our psychological well-being. But we live in a rich narrative ecology of stories. There are stories all around us. And some of those stories
带有一个救赎性的转折，对吧？这一切最终都迎刃而解了，她在最后说，结果他们甚至变得更好了。所以在经历了一场如此戏剧性和可怕的事件之后，能够看到这种转变，确实是一件了不起的事情。乔纳森，请多谈谈救赎故事对我们福祉的影响。因此，研究一遍又一遍地证明，当我们能够将消极的经历转化为救赎性的东西时，这往往对我们的心理健康有益。但我们生活在一个丰富的叙事生态中。我们身边到处都是故事。其中一些故事
exert more influence over our lives than others. So scholars in my field call these potent stories master narratives. Master narratives tend to be ubiquitous, but invisible. We only see them when we bump into them, like when our life story doesn't fit in some way with the master narrative. And there's excellent work by Dan McAdams suggesting that redemption is an especially potent American master narrative. And I would say especially with cancer patients. We have a strong master narrative of what it means to be a cancer patient in the United States. Cancer is a battle and it's supposed to show you how strong you are. And that kind of redemptive spin on cancer has two kinds of impacts on patients. First, if you get a
比其他故事对我们的生活施加了更大的影响。因此，我领域的学者将这些强有力的故事称为主叙事（master narratives）。主叙事往往无处不在，却又无形无踪。只有当我们在生活中与之碰撞时才会发现它们，比如当我们的生活故事在某种程度上与主叙事不契合时。丹·麦克亚当斯（Dan McAdams）做过一项非常出色的研究，表明救赎是一种特别强有力的美国主叙事。我要说，特别是在癌症患者中。在美国，对于成为一名癌症患者意味着什么，我们有着强烈的的主叙事。癌症是一场战斗，它应该向你展示你有多坚强。这种对癌症的救赎性解读对患者有两种影响。首先，如果你
cast against your will in a war story, it's going to influence your behavior. So there's research suggesting that the war metaphor might actually lead people to pay less attention to health supporting behaviors like drinking and smoking less or eating healthier. Right, if you're going into battle, you might not care as much about those things, but those can actually make a difference to your overall health. But second, I've talked with cancer patients who don't feel like cancer made them stronger. And so if cancer isn't some complex gift in disguise, right, if it just sucks, then not only are you sick, but you're not telling a story about being sick that anyone wants to hear. And indeed, there is research demonstrating that Americans love to hear redemption stories
违背意愿被卷入一个战争故事中，它就会影响你的行为。因此，有研究表明，战争隐喻实际上可能会导致人们减少关注那些支持健康的的行为，比如少喝酒、少抽烟或吃得更健康。没错，如果你要奔赴战场，你可能就不会那么在意这些事情了，但这些其实会对你的整体健康产生影响。但其次，我和一些癌症患者交谈过，他们并不觉得癌症让他们变得更坚强。因此，如果癌症不是某种伪装的复杂礼物，没错，如果它只是烂透了，那么不仅你生病了，而且你也没有讲述一个关于生病的故事是任何人想听的。事实上，确实有研究表明，美国人喜欢听救赎故事
and don't love contamination stories. So when you narrate your own life in ways that don't fit with cultural master narratives, it can be a double whammy. When we come back, can the master narrative that tells us to tell redemption stories become a form of pressure on people who've been through tough times? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Jonathan Adler has found that the way we tell stories changes the way we feel about our lives. He says that when we start stories from a place of success and well-being and end the tale with
而讨厌听污染故事。因此，当你以不符合文化主叙事的方式来叙述自己的生活时，这可能会成为双重打击。当我们回来时，告诉我们要讲述救赎故事的主叙事，会变成对那些经历过艰难时期的人的一种压力吗？您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。乔纳森·阿德勒发现，我们讲述故事的方式改变了我们对生活的感受。他说，当我们从成功和幸福的地方开始讲故事，并以
disaster and tragedy, we are telling what he calls a contamination story. Things started out great and then turned bad. On the other hand, when we tell stories that start out with difficulty and challenge, but end in a positive place, these redemption stories are often associated with better well-being. Jonathan, we heard from a listener who said that the pressure to tell redemption stories can sometimes feel unfair. Here's Kristen. Since my children were young, I've lost both my parents to cancer,
灾难和悲剧结束故事时，我们讲述的就是他所谓的污染故事。事情一开始很好，后来却变糟了。另一方面，当我们讲述以困难和挑战开始、却以积极的结果结束的故事时，这些救赎故事通常与更好的幸福感息息相关。乔纳森，我们听到一位听众说，讲述救赎故事的压力有时会让人觉得不公平。这是克里斯滕。自从我的孩子们很小的时候起，我就因癌症失去了双亲，
had to manage the business of death and of grieving on my own as being an only child. And my children also had witnessed. a violent attack that happened on the porch of our old home. I also found out that I had two rare medical conditions. One of them took a few years and a lot of stress to get diagnosed. And the other one is, so just requires a lot of stressful surveillance. So this is just a short part of the list. But I definitely felt the pressure for a redemptive spin on my life. Basically, I spent my last several years just dealing with the fall out of this. I have no elevator pitch to give to people at parties about, you know, how my life has somehow come to a meaningful culmination out of all
作为独生子女，我不得不独自处理死亡和悲伤的事务。我的孩子们还目睹了发生在旧家门廊上的一场暴力袭击。我还发现自己患有两种罕见的疾病。其中一种花了几年的时间和巨大的压力才被诊断出来。另一种则需要大量有压力的监测。这只是这份清单的一小部分。但我确实感到了要为我的生活赋予救赎色彩的压力。基本上，我过去几年都在应对这一切带来的余波。在聚会上，我无法向人们发表简短的电梯演讲，讲述我的生活是如何从这一切中不知何故走向了有意义的高潮。
of this. But, you know, I guess what's gotten me through is just that I realize that we were hit by an onslaught of events that most of which were out of our control. And, we bear the scars, but we're still putting one foot in front of the other, and our story is still continuing. Thank you. So Jonathan, you were talking a moment ago about how, in some ways, we have this master narrative that we're supposed to come up with a redemption story. And I feel I can very much hear that in the way Kristen is telling the story of the many challenges she has encountered in her life. Yeah. Wow. Kristen, I am so sorry to hear about this. I don't know how listeners are feeling, but my body feels different just hearing what Kristen has been through.
但是，你知道，我想支撑我度过难关的是，我意识到我们遭到了猛烈事件的袭击，其中大多数是我们无法控制的。而且，我们带着伤痕，但我们仍在向前迈进，我们的故事仍在继续。谢谢。所以乔纳森，你刚才谈到，在某种程度上，我们有这样一种主叙事，即我们应该想出一个救赎的故事。我觉得我完全能在克里斯滕讲述她在生活中遇到的许多挑战的方式中听到这一点。是的。哇。克里斯滕，听到这些我很难过。我不知道听众们现在是什么感觉，但仅仅听到克里斯滕所经历的一切，我的身体就有了不同的感觉。
So I'm really grateful for sharing this hard story. I think it's really important to remember that negative experiences are a part of everyone's life. And if we just ignore them, we miss out on an invitation to grow from them. But we've already talked about master narratives and looked at redemption as one example of an American master narrative. And I think there's a real rush to redemption in our culture where we want to get through the negative as quickly as possible, put a nice redemptive bow on it and move on. But negative experiences can also force us out of the story that we've sort of gotten used to living. And in doing so, they can offer an invitation to see things differently. I want to be really clear that different ways of seeing things don't
所以我非常感谢她分享这个艰难的故事。我认为非常重要的是要记住，负面的经历是每个人生活的一部分。如果我们只是忽视它们，就会错过一个从中成长的机会。但我们已经讨论过主叙事，并将救赎视为美国主叙事的一个例子。我认为在我们的文化中有一种对救赎的盲目冲动，我们希望尽快摆脱负面情绪，给它系上一个漂亮的救赎蝴蝶结然后继续前进。但负面的经历也会迫使我们跳出那种我们已经习惯了的生活故事。在这个过程中，它们可以提供一个以不同视角看待事物的机会。我想明确指出的是，看待事物的新方式并不
necessarily feel good. Some things are just awful and we just need to acknowledge their role in our lives without needing to transform them into something positive. But even when feeling good isn't an option, we can find meaning. And that active search for meaning is what it sounds like Kristen has been working to do. And that in and of itself is a worthwhile and valuable goal. Redemption isn't the only option in the wake of negative experiences. I'm so glad you mentioned that, Jonathan, because I was struck when Kristen said, I feel better knowing some things are out of my control. So she's not necessarily telling a story that says things have taken a dramatic upswing, but she is saying her own understanding
一定感觉良好。有些事情就是糟糕透顶，我们只需要承认它们在我们生活中的作用，而不需要把它们变成积极的东西。但即使感觉良好不是一种选择，我们也能找到意义。这种对意义的积极寻找，听起来正是克里斯滕一直在努力做的事情。这本身就是一个值得追求的宝贵目标。在经历负面事件之后，救赎并不是唯一的选择。我很高兴你提到这一点，乔纳森，因为当克里斯滕说“知道有些事情是我无法控制的，这让我感觉更好”时，我深受触动。所以她不一定是在讲一个事情发生了戏剧性好转的故事，但她是在说，她对生活的理解
about her life has changed as a result of these negative experiences. Exactly. So if we were sort of technically looking, examining her narrative, we might see evidence of what we call exploratory processing, that search for meaning, which is different than redemption, right? Redemption turns negative, positive. Exploratory processing can lead us to a sense of meaningfulness, but it might not feel good. But that search for meaning is still a really worthwhile pursuit. One common story we heard from many listeners had to do with an injury or an illness. Here's one from Allison. I think I'm a pretty positive person, and I think part of that is telling my big life stories in a redemptive way. About a year and a half ago, my husband was diagnosed with stage three colon cancer, and I think we sort of thought it was very scary and crappy, but we did what we had to do to get through it, and now we just feel so lucky that he's healthy, and as far as we know, he's cancer-free.
由于这些负面的经历而发生了改变。完全正确。因此，如果我们从技术层面审视、检查她的叙事，我们可能会看到我们所谓的探索性加工（exploratory processing）的证据，也就是对意义的寻找，这与救赎不同，对吧？救赎把消极变成积极。探索性加工可以带给我们一种意义感，但它可能感觉并不好。但这种对意义的寻找仍然是一个非常值得追求的目标。我们从许多听众那里听到一个常见的故事，都与受伤或疾病有关。这是来自艾森的一段话。我认为我是一个非常积极的人，我认为部分原因是我以救赎的方式讲述了我生活中的重大故事。大约一年半前，我丈夫被诊断出患有三期结肠癌，我想我们当时觉得这非常可怕和糟糕，但我们做了我们必须做的事来度过难关，现在我们感到非常幸运，他很健康，而且据我们所知，他已经没有癌症了。
So it was a really tough time in our lives, but we came out the other side, and I think I think it just makes us more grateful for each other. So Jonathan, Allison's story is clearly a redemption story, the way she's telling it. But I'm wondering, is it possible that sometimes we need to let some time pass before we can see the redemption arc of a story? When Allison and her husband were in the midst of dealing with this cancer, it's possible that it might have been harder to see the story through a redemptive lens. Yeah, I imagine that's true, having talked with many cancer patients and their loved ones,
所以这是我们生活中非常艰难的一段时期，但我们挺了过来，我想这只是让我们对彼此更加感激。所以乔纳森，从艾森讲述的方式来看，她的故事显然是一个救赎的故事。但我在想，有时我们是否需要让一些时间过去，然后才能看到一个故事的救赎弧光？当艾森和她的丈夫正处于应对这种癌症的艰难时期时，要通过救赎的镜头来看待这个故事可能更困难。是的，我想这是真的，在与许多癌症患者及其亲属交谈过后，
And indeed, I wonder if Allison and her husband felt pushed into, you know, sort of a cancer master narrative, which is really not about redemption at the beginning. There's always the promise of redemption at the end. But that kind of story really centers a different theme, which we call agency, which is sort of the degree to which you are in the driver's seat of your life versus being batted around by external forces. And again, these are themes and stories. No one is completely in control of their life. But the war story of cancer is a high agency story. And sometimes when people are in the face of real existential threat, being reminded of your agency can feel good. So I agree with you. It's often hard to do
事实上，我不知道艾森和她的丈夫是否觉得自己被推入了一种癌症的主叙事中，这种叙事在开始时其实并不是关于救赎的。最后总会有救赎的承诺。但那种故事真正聚焦于另一个主题，我们称之为能动性（agency），这有点类似于你在生活中是处于驾驶座上，还是被外部力量左右的程度。再说一次，这些都是故事中的主题。没有人能完全掌控自己的生活。但癌症的战争故事是一个高能动性的故事。有时，当人们面临真正的生存威胁时，被提醒自己的能动性会感觉很好。所以我同意你的看法。通常很难在负面经历的中途做到
redemption in the middle of negative experiences, though I think people feel pressure to do that all the time. And so I often encourage people to resist the rush to redemption and to acknowledge the real awful parts of negative experiences before thinking about whether there's a redemptive end or not. You talked a moment ago, Jonathan, about the importance of agency. And I want to just stay with this for a moment longer. A lot of people feel bad things happen to me, and whether that's an illness or an injury or lose a loved one or your home burns down. Many of these things are external things that happen to us. And many of us then feel like we are effectively buffeted around by the winds of life. Talk a moment about how the act of storytelling itself might be a way of
救赎，尽管我认为人们一直感到有这样做的压力。所以我经常鼓励人们抵制对救赎的急于求成，并承认负面经历中那些真正糟糕的部分，然后再去考虑是否存在一个救赎的结局。乔纳森，你刚才谈到了能动性的重要性。我想在这个话题上多停留一会儿。很多人觉得不好的事情发生在了我身上，无论是疾病、受伤、失去亲人还是房子被烧毁。许多事情都是发生在身上的外部事件。然后我们中的许多人就会觉得自己实际上被生活的风浪吹来吹去。请谈谈讲故事的行为本身可能是如何成为一种
regaining some sense of agency. Yeah, this is actually something I've been thinking a lot about recently. Certainly one of the things that drew me to the field of studying narrative identity was the idea that you can't always control what happens to you, but you can control the story you tell about what happens to you. And to a large extent, I think that is true. You know, as I've said, we're both the main character and the narrator of our life story, and we do have agency to tell stories that support our well-being. So I don't want to diminish the importance of that at all. But at the same time, our stories don't just exist in our heads, right? Stories are meant to be told. And if you're telling a story about your life that other people don't affirm,
重新获得某种能动感的方式。是的，这其实是我最近一直在深入思考的一个问题。当然，吸引我进入研究叙事认同领域的其中一个原因，就是这样一个观点：你并不总能控制发生在你身上的事情，但你可以控制你所讲述的关于发生在你身上的事情的故事。在很大程度上，我认为这是真的。你知道，正如我所说，我们既是自己生活故事的主角，也是叙述者，我们确实有能动性去讲述支持我们幸福的故事。所以我绝不想贬低这种重要性的价值。但与此同时，我们的故事并不只存在于我们的脑海中，对吧？故事是要讲给别人听的。如果你讲述的关于你生活的故事没有得到其他人的肯定，
it's actually quite hard to keep living out that story, where people lose control over their life stories. Can you talk about how the big events in our lives, weddings, the birth of children, the death of loved ones, how these might be particularly powerful occasions to tell both contamination and redemption stories? Yeah, so big events. like that, to a certain extent, play into a different kind of master narrative. We call this in my field the cultural concept of biography, which means in any given culture, there's sort of an expected timeline of milestones. And so when your life coincides with those milestones, there's a socially acceptable pressure for you to narrate those. So I was doing a study years ago where we
那么要继续把那个故事活下去其实是相当困难的，人们会失去对自己生活故事的掌控。你能谈谈我们生活中的重大事件，比如婚礼、孩子的出生、亲人的离世，这些如何能成为讲述污染故事和救赎故事的特别强有力的契机吗？是的，所以像这样的重大事件，在某种程度上，迎合了另一种不同类型的主叙事。我们在我的领域称之为生物学的文化概念（cultural concept of biography），这意味着在任何给定的文化中，都存在一种预期的里程碑时间线。因此，当你的生活与这些里程碑巧合时，就会产生一种社会可接受的压力，要求你去讲述这些经历。所以多年前我在做一项研究时，我们
were reading transcripts of entire life stories. And my students who were working with the narratives said, I can't read another high point that is about a wedding or the birth of a first child. And it's just like, right. Those are such straightforward stories for people to point to as the high point of their life. And indeed, it is often the big moments of our lives that serve as chapter breaks, that serve as anchor points in our stories. But I also want to remind everyone that it doesn't have to just be objective big moments. I've read and interviewed people with absolutely gorgeous, very small moments that have very big subjective meaning associated with them. And so, you know, that meaningful conversation, you know, over a bowl of Cheerios could turn out
正在阅读整个生活故事的文字记录。那些从事叙事研究的学生说：“我读不下去了，不想再读另一个关于婚礼或第一个孩子出生的生活高潮了。”这就好像，对吧。对人们来说，这些都是非常直接的故事，可以作为他们生活的高潮。事实上，往往是我们生活中的重大 moments（时刻）构成了章节的断裂点，成为了我们故事中的锚点。但我也想提醒大家，这不一定非得是客观上的重大时刻。我读过并采访过一些人，他们拥有绝对美妙、非常微小的时刻，却带有非常强大的主观意义。所以，你知道，在麦片粥碗旁进行的那场有意义的对话，
to be a high point or a turning point in your life. It doesn't just have to be the big milestone events. It's really about the subjective meaning that we associate. with our experiences. We've looked at the reliability of memory in many episodes of Hidden Brain, Jonathan, and it's fair to say that the scientific consensus is that our memories are not very accurate, even when it comes to the big events in our lives. How much does the accuracy of a narrative in our lives matter? Yeah, this is such an important topic.
最终可能会成为你生活中的高潮或转折点。它不一定非得是重大的里程碑事件。这实际上关乎我们赋予经历的主观意义。乔纳森，我们在《隐藏的大脑》的许多节目中都探讨过记忆的可靠性，可以说科学共识是，我们的记忆并不是非常准确，即使在我们生活中的重大事件上也是如此。我们生活中的叙事的准确性到底有多重要？是的，这是一个非常重要的话题。
I guess it depends on mattering for what, right? So fundamentally, stories are reconstructions, right? As you said, there's excellent work on memory demonstrating that we're not particularly accurate reporters of the things that happened to us. And there's good reason for that, right? Our memory systems evolved to help us interpret the present and anticipate the future. The present and the future are never exact replicas of the past. So if we could only hold on to the past precisely as it happened, we actually wouldn't have the cognitive flexibility to navigate our lives so adaptively. So I like to say that our life stories are based on a true story.
我想这取决于它对什么而言重要，对吧？从根本上讲，故事是重构，对吧？正如你所说，关于记忆的出色研究表明，我们并不是发生在我们身上的事情的特别准确的记录者。这有充分的理由，对吧？我们的记忆系统进化是为了帮助我们解释现在和预测未来。现在和未来永远不是过去的精确复制品。因此，如果我们只能一字不差地保留过去的发生方式，我们实际上就不会具备认知灵活性来以高度适应性的方式应对我们的生活。所以我喜欢说，我们的生活故事是基于一个真实的故事。
Right. If you are telling a story about wildly improbable things that could have happened to you, no one's going to believe that story, and that's going to make it hard for you to live that story. But we just don't have access to the objective history of our lives. We're always reconstructing the past, interpreting the present, imagining the future. So I often refer to my field as a science of subjectivity, right? Using the tools of science to understand the ways in which people turn their experience. into meaning. When we come back, Jonathan answers more of your questions about the science of storytelling. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. In 2006, the writer and journalist Joan Didion published a collection of nonfiction pieces titled,
对吧。如果你讲述的是一个可能发生在你身上的极其荒谬而不大可能的事情的故事，没有人会相信那个故事，这就会使你很难把那个故事活出来。但我们就是无法接触到我们生活的客观历史。我们总是在重构过去，解释现在，想象未来。所以我经常把我的领域称为主观性科学（science of subjectivity），对吧？利用科学工具来理解人们如何将他们的经历转化为意义。当我们回来时，乔纳森将回答更多关于讲故事的科学的问题。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。2006年，作家兼记者琼·狄迪恩（Joan Didion）出版了一本名为
We Tell Ourself Stories in Order to Live. At Olden College, psychologist Jonathan Adler couldn't agree more with the premise of that title, but he might edit the title to say, we tell ourselves stories to shape how we live. He joins us today for our latest installment of your questions answered. Jonathan, we heard from lots of listeners who are in the process of rewriting their personal narratives. Maybe they're in a transition point in their lives or just reflecting on events that happened to them in the past, and they're trying to figure out, how do I reframe my story in a useful way? Here's listener, Denise.
《我们为了生存而讲述故事》（We Tell Ourselves Stories in Order to Live）的非虚构作品集。在欧林学院，心理学家乔纳森·阿德勒对这个书名的前提不能再赞同了，但他可能会把书名修改为：我们为了塑造生存方式而讲述故事。他今天加入我们，参加我们最新的“解答你的问题”环节。乔纳森，我们听到了许多听众的声音，他们正处于重写个人叙事的过程中。也许他们正处于生活中的转型期，或者只是在反思过去发生在自己身上的事情，他们试图弄清楚：我该如何以一种有用的方式重构我的故事？这是听众丹尼斯（Denise）。
So I thought I would share my story, which is about my experience of living with tinnitus, which started in my 20s, was a visitor. now and then through the years. But as I got older, it was a little bit more in volume and was with me constantly. I did go to a doctor who pretty much said there isn't much they can do and felt discouraged. And yeah, there was some anxiety about it until I had a change of story. And my story was that if this is going to be with me all the time, it might as well be my friend. And it could be even more than that. It could be a part of me, almost a helper, a guardian angel. Once I change the story, I am what you might call habituated to this sound, and I haven't really
所以我想分享我的故事，这是关于我与耳鸣共处的生活经历，耳鸣始于我二十多岁的时候，它偶尔会作为不速之客在这些年里出现。但随着年龄的增长，它的音量变大了一点，并且一直伴随着我。我确实去看过医生，医生基本上说他们无能为力，这让我感到沮丧。是的，这带来了一些焦虑，直到我的故事发生了转变。我的故事是，如果这个声音要一直伴随着我，那它不妨成为我的朋友。而且它可以比这更多。它可以是我的一部分，几乎是一个帮手，一个守护天使。一旦我改变了这个故事，我对这个声音就可以说是习以为常了，从那以后我真的没有
experienced any nervousness about it since. The new story is that tinnitus can be my friend. So, Jonathan, you said that a story like this might be an example of what you call integration. What do you mean by that term? Yeah. First of all, let me just say, wow, it is not everyone who can take those chronic challenges that get thrown at us and reframe them in quite that way. And if Denise was able to do that in an authentic way, that's really spectacular. So I really see this story as highlighting, yeah, like you said, the importance of integration in storytelling. Some of the work that I've done with Lauren Mitchell and others really tried to illustrate the ways in which integration is one of the central developmental tasks of midlife. In adolescence and early adulthood, we're really laying down early drafts of our life story.
经历过任何与之相关的紧张情绪。新的故事是，耳鸣可以成为我的朋友。所以，乔纳森，你说过像这样的故事可能是你所说的“整合”（integration）的一个例子。你这个术语是什么意思？是的。首先，我要说，哇，并不是每个人都能把抛向我们的那些长期挑战以这种方式重新诠释。如果丹尼斯能以一种真实的方式做到这一点，那真的是太棒了。所以我真的认为这个故事突显了，是的，就像你说的，整合在讲故事中的重要性。我和劳伦·米切尔（Lauren Mitchell）以及其他人做的一些研究，真正试图说明整合是中年期核心发展任务之一的方式。在青春期和成年早期，我们实际上在打磨我们生活故事的早期草稿。
In midlife, our job is to nurture those stories. maintaining them when that's what's called for, helping them develop when that's what's needed, like in Denise's story. Many events like the onset of medical diagnoses can disrupt our sense of integration. And of course, many negative things like getting a medical diagnosis or getting divorced or getting fired, those things can make us feel like we've lost our sense of continuity. But positive things can also do that too. Like becoming a parent can often be a huge shake-up to identity. And so the work in midlife is really about striving for integration, figuring out what parts of the story from before the disruptive event ought to
到了中年，我们的工作是培育这些故事。在需要时维护它们，在需要时帮助它们发展，就像在丹尼斯的 pentru 故事中那样。许多事件，如医疗诊断的开始，会破坏我们的整合感。当然，许多负面事情，比如得到医疗诊断、离婚或被解雇，这些事情会让我们觉得自己失去了连续感。但积极的事情也能做到这一点。比如成为父母往往会给身份认同带来巨大的震撼。因此，中年期的工作实际上是争取整合，弄清楚在破坏性事件发生之前的故事中，哪些部分应该
still be part of our identity and which parts need to change. Can you talk a moment about what Denise is doing here? She's basically transforming something that's a negative experience into something that is a positive experience. I have to confess I sometimes do this myself if I'm waiting for something and it feels excruciating to be waiting and waiting for an, you know, an airplane to take off, for example. You know, I'll tell myself a story. And the story is, you know, these are the last 20 minutes of my life. And suddenly, I want those 20 minutes to extend as far as they possibly can. And I'm not, you know, anxious or worried or exasperated by the delay anymore. Can you talk a bit about whether this is an act of storytelling and if this is an effective
仍然是我们身份的一部分，哪些部分需要改变。你能谈谈丹尼斯在这里做什么吗？她基本上把一个消极的经历转化成了一个积极的经历。我必须承认，有时我自己也会这样做，如果我在等待某事，等待的过程会让人觉得度日如年，例如在等待飞机起飞时。你知道，我会给自己讲一个故事。这个故事是，你知道，这是我生命的最后20分钟。突然之间，我希望这20分钟尽可能地延长。我不再对延误感到焦虑、担忧或恼火了。你能谈谈这是否是一种讲故事的行为，以及这对于我们的心理健康来说是否是一种有效的
form of storytelling for our mental health? It sure sounds like it in your case and in Denise's case where you can take a negative experience that's not in your control and transform it by changing the story that you're telling yourself about that. I think indeed for many of the challenging experiences in our life like Denise is that leave a lasting mark that aren't going to go away. We have to learn how to live with them. So she initially framed her tinnitus as a visitor.
讲故事的形式吗？听起来在你的情况和丹尼斯的情况下确实如此，你可以把一个你无法控制的消极经历，通过改变你对自己讲述的故事来将其转化。我认为，对于我们生活中许多像丹尼斯那样留下持久印记且不会消失的具有挑战性的经历，确实如此。我们必须学会如何与它们共处。她最初将她的耳鸣描述为一个访客。
And then it became a friend. And I thought, wow, that's really quite a transformation there. If we can see the negative things that happened to us as teachers who are there to help us, as other characters who are there to help us, that's really amazing. But then Denise goes one step further, and she really does the hard work of integrating it into her own sense of self. that really transforms the main character of the story, Denise herself, and really makes room in that character for both positive and negative experiences to coexist.
然后它变成了朋友。我想，哇，这真的是一个相当大的转变。如果我们能把发生在我们身上的负面事情看作是来帮助我们的老师，看作是来帮助我们的其他角色，那真的很了不起。但随后丹尼斯又向前迈进了一步，她真正完成了将它整合到她自己的自我感中的艰辛工作。这真正改变了故事的主角，也就是丹尼斯本人，并在那个角色中真正腾出了空间，让积极和消极的经历能够共存。
Jonathan, when we lose a loved one, we often reflect not just on the story of our life, but on the story of this other person's life. A listener named Raquel called in with this experience. In 2014, I had just finished graduate school and I was starting a new job. The day before my 27th birthday, my sister called to tell me that my dad had been in a car accident. Sadly, he passed away a few days later. Fast forward to 2019, I began helping with a grief support group at my church, and I had to tell the story of my dad's passing.
乔纳森，当我们失去亲人时，我们常常不仅在反思我们自己人生的故事，还在反思另一个人人生的故事。一位名叫拉奎尔（Raquel）的听众打来电话，分享了这样的经历。2014年，我刚读完研究生，开始了一份新工作。在我27岁生日的前一天，我姐姐打电话告诉我，我爸爸遭遇了一场车祸。不幸的是，他几天后去世了。快进到2019年，我开始在我的教堂里协助一个悲伤支持小组，我不得不讲述我父亲去世的故事。
with each new group. I started to notice things in the story that changed my perspective on it. Since my dad had passed, I had looked on that time with regret for not having prioritized time with him because of my new job. I felt awful that I wasn't able to say a proper goodbye or make time to spend with him in what I realized now were his job. last days. But as I told the story to the grief group, I remembered that I had had a sense of foreboding, actually, around my 27th birthday. I had heard stories of celebrities dying specifically at this age, Kurt Cobain, Amy Winehouse, Jimmy Hendricks, and it made me wonder if something might happen to me. And I realized something did happen, but it happened to my dad. Now I look back and I tell a story of my dad taking my place.
对每个新小组都是如此。我开始注意到故事中改变了我对它看法的细节。自从我父亲去世以来，我一直带着遗憾回顾那段时光，因为新工作而没有把与他相处的时间放在首位。我感到非常糟糕，因为我没能好好道别，也没能抽出时间在他现在我意识到是他的最后日子里陪伴他。但当我向悲伤小组讲述这个故事时，我记起其实在我27岁生日左右，我曾有一种不祥的预感。我听过名人具体在这个年龄去世的故事，比如科特·柯本（Kurt Cobain）、艾米·怀恩豪斯（Amy Winehouse）、吉米·亨德里克斯（Jimmy Hendrix），这让我怀疑自己身上是否会发生什么事。我意识到确实发生了什么，但它发生在了我爸爸身上。现在我回想起来，我讲述的是我爸爸替我承受的故事。
Maybe I had been the target that 27th birthday curse coming for me, but my dad protected me. I know there's no evidence for this, but knowing my dad, it's not a stretch to believe that he would gladly give his life up to give us what we needed. So now I see the ways my dad's love for teaching and learning live on in me. And I try to honor these traits and the gift I feel he's given me. Jonathan, I'm wondering what you make of Raquel's story. Oh, who's publishing it? It's gorgeous. I mean, what a poignant but beautifully told story of this transformation.
也许我才是那个27岁生日诅咒的目标，但爸爸保护了我。我知道没有任何证据支持这一点，但了解我爸爸的为人，相信他会为了给我们提供我们需要的东西而甘愿献出生命，这并不是一种夸大。所以现在我看到了我父亲对教学和学习的热爱是如何在我身上延续的。我试着去纪念这些特质以及我觉得他给我的礼物。乔纳森，我想知道你对拉奎尔的故事有何看法。哦，谁在出版它？这太美妙了。我的意思是，这是一个多么辛酸但又讲述得如此优美的关于这种转变的故事。
You know, I think grief is often one of those negative experiences that doesn't neatly lend itself to redemption. And I don't know that what Raquel is doing there is redeeming the death of her father itself, right? She still acknowledges how sad that is, how she still has regrets about the last few days of his life. But what she's doing is looking towards her own agency and her act as the storyteller to think about the ways in which the storytelling itself offers her a different way to relate to that negative experience without transforming it itself. The storytelling doesn't undermine the sadness. I'm sure it doesn't stop the waves of grief from crashing over her,
你知道，我认为悲伤往往是那些不容易带来救赎的负面经历之一。我不知道拉奎尔在那里做的是不是在救赎她父亲的死本身，对吧？她仍然承认那是多么悲伤，她对他的生命最后几天仍然感到遗憾。但她所做的是将目光投向她自己的能动性以及她作为讲故事者的行为，去思考讲故事本身如何为她提供了一种不同的方式来与那种负面经历建立联系，而无需转化经历本身。讲故事并没有削弱悲伤。我确信它并没有阻止悲伤的浪潮向她袭来，
but it does give her an opportunity to add to that experience. And indeed, as I've been saying, our stories are not only living in our own heads. We tell the stories to other people, and other people tell their stories to us. They become important characters in our own life stories. One thing I heard in Raquel's story is that she really, told the story of her father's passing over and over again, and something in that repetitive retelling actually changed the story in her own mind. We heard from a listener named Michelle who went through something similar. I've struggled with an unexplained illness,
但它确实给了她一个为那种经历增添意义的机会。而且确实，正如我一直所说的那样，我们的故事不仅生活在我们自己的脑海中。我们把故事讲给别人听，别人也把他们的故事讲给我们。他们成为了我们自己生活故事中的重要角色。我在拉奎尔的故事中听到的一点是，她真的把父亲去世的故事讲了一遍又一遍，而这种重复讲述中的某些东西实际上改变了她自己心中的故事。我们听到一位名叫米歇尔（Michelle）的听众经历过类似的事情。我一直在与一种原因不明的疾病作斗争，
unexplained symptoms for the last 12 years. I've gone through many doctors and many tests, and no one can really tell me what's wrong. And it can be really unsettling to have something unexplained go on for so long. And I've turned to voice recorder. I've used the voice recorder on my phone just to record myself talking about it and working through it for the last 12 years. And it's been really helpful. And as humans, we want to find meaning and things and we want to find patterns and try to make sense of it. And I feel like it's really helped me do that. I'm kind of loving the questions at this point. And I think this whole experience has opened my heart to other people who are going through uncertain times. And it has opened me up more to all the questions
在过去的12年里一直有原因不明的症状。我找过很多医生，做过很多检查，没有人能真正告诉我出了什么问题。长时间经历原因不明的状况可能会让人感到非常不安。在过去的12年里，我转向了录音机。我一直在用手机上的录音机录下自己谈论这件事以及努力克服它的过程。这真的很有帮助。作为人类，我们希望在事物中找到意义，我们希望找到规律并试图理解它。我觉得这真的帮我做到了这一点。我此时此刻非常喜欢这些问题。我认为这段经历打开了我的心扉，去接纳其他正在经历不确定时期的人。它让我更加敞开心扉去面对我生活中的所有问题
and uncertainties in my life. Thanks for letting me share my story. What's interesting about Michelle's story, Jonathan, is that in working through the story over and over again for 12 years, she has found fresh insights in it. Is this something that you find, in the stories that you hear from people telling the same story over and over again can change our stories themselves? Yeah, yeah. I think this is a great question because it invites us to think more, not just about the content of the stories we tell and the themes, but how sharing stories with others help shape them. So when we tell a story, the version in our head gets shaped by the interpersonal context. Who are we telling the story to? What kind of audience are they? And then the
和不确定性。谢谢你们让我分享我的故事。乔纳森，米歇尔的故事有趣的地方在于，在连续12年一遍又一遍地梳理这个故事的过程中，她从中找到了新的见解。你是否发现，人们一遍又一遍地讲述同一个故事，确实可以改变我们对故事本身的看法？是的，是的。我认为这是一个很好的问题，因为它邀请我们不仅要思考我们讲述的故事的内容和主题，还要思考与他人分享故事如何有助于塑造它们。因此，当我们讲述一个故事时，我们头脑中的版本会被人际交往环境所塑造。我们在把故事讲给谁听？他们是怎样听众？然后是
feedback that we get both verbally and nonverbally during the experience of storytelling will inevitably shape the way we consolidate that story in our mind and then the way we tell it the next time. Our stories always serve a psychological function in the present. So in addition to the impact of prior tellings, the meaning of specific stories changes over time, leading us to tell stories differently. That doesn't mean we're lying. It just means we're always thinking about our passed through the lens of the present. And indeed, I did some of my clinical work at a veterans hospital, and one of the leading therapeutic approaches to treating post-traumatic stress disorder essentially asks people, once they're ready, once they're prepared with tools for navigating
我们在讲故事过程中得到的言语和非言语反馈，不可避免地会塑造我们在脑海中巩固这个故事的方式，以及下一次我们讲述它的方式。我们的故事总是在当下发挥心理功能。因此，除了先前讲述的影响之外，特定故事的意义会随着时间而改变，导致我们以不同的方式讲述故事。这并不意味着我们在撒谎。这只是意味着我们总是通过当下的镜头来思考我们的过去。事实上，我曾在一家退伍军人医院做过一些临床工作，治疗创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）的主要治疗方法之一，本质上是要求人们一旦准备好，一旦掌握了应对创伤的工具，
it, to tell the story of their traumatic experience over and over. And we do find that that kind of exposure to the story of the traumatic event can help transform it for people, not just in the meaning that they make, but in the physiology of their bodies while they're telling it. Now, narrative psychology doesn't just have to apply to individuals. As you've indicated, Jonathan, it's also relevant to the collective stories we tell in our country, our workplaces, our families. We heard from a listener in the United States named Debbie, who writes, I'm at a fairly good place in my personal life now. However, I find that my thinking about our country and the world
就要把他们的创伤经历一遍又一遍地讲出来。我们确实发现，这种对创伤事件故事的接触可以帮助人们转化它，不仅是在他们赋予的意义上，而且在他们讲述时身体的生理反应上。现在，叙事心理学不仅适用于个人。正如你所指出的，乔纳森，它也与我们在国家、工作场所、家庭中讲述的集体故事息息相关。我们听到美国一位名叫黛比（Debbie）的听众写道：我现在个人生活处于一个相当不错的阶段。然而，我发现我对我们国家和世界的思考
is becoming increasingly pessimistic. I'm wondering how do we create a better mindset or a better story or a more positive story in the face of what's going on in these divided states today. I think our national story is turning very negative and I'm wondering if there's a way that we can reframe that. What do you think, Jonathan? Can we rewrite our general cultural narrative?
变得越来越悲观。我想知道，面对当今这些分裂国家中正在发生的事情，我们该如何创造一种更好的心态、更好的故事或更积极的故事。我认为我们的国家故事正在变得非常消极，我想知道是否有办法我们可以重构这一点。乔纳森，你觉得呢？我们能否重写我们的整体文化叙事？
Well, so all narratives, individual or cultural, are based on a true story, right? So to a certain extent, if you want to see things change in a culture, you have to advocate to the levers of power in that culture to make things actually change, and that will help change the story. But as I've talked about master narratives, we so often experience them as top down, right? Like our feeling of being penned in by stories around us about things like cancer or gender or race or politics or many other, you know, master narratives in our culture. But just as stories play out in the dynamic space between individual people, they also play out in the dialogue between individuals and broader cultural narratives. So there's another scholar in my field, Phil Hammack, who says that when
嗯，所有的叙事，无论是个人的还是文化的，都是基于一个真实的故事，对吧？所以在某种程度上，如果你想看到一个文化中的事物发生改变，你必须向该文化中的权力杠杆进行倡导以促使事情真正发生改变，这会有助于改变故事。但正如我所讨论过的主叙事，我们经常将它们体验为自上而下的，对吧？就像我们感到被周围关于癌症、性别、种族、政治或许多其他文化中的主叙事所束缚。但正如故事在个人之间的动态空间中展开一样，它们也在个人与更广泛的文化叙事之间的对话中展开。所以我的领域的另一位学者菲尔·哈马克（Phil Hammack）说，当
we narrate our own individual life story, we really only have two options. to either reproduce or to push back on the master narratives in our cultural context. It's kind of the ultimate, you know, the personalist political. But that means that the power dynamic works in a bottom up way too. In fact, the only way cultural master narratives change is by individual people being willing to share their own stories that don't fit with the master narrative, right? Doing so, as I said before, provides other people with narrative options that they may not considered before, and it invites them to narrate their lives differently. So individual life
我们叙述我们自己的个人生活故事时，我们实际上只有两个选择：要么复制，要么推回我们在文化背景中的主叙事。这有点像是终极的，你知道的，个人即政治。但这意味着权力动态也是以自下而上的方式运作的。事实上，文化主叙事改变的唯一途径是个人愿意分享他们不符合主叙事的故事，对吧？正如我之前所说，这样做为其他人提供了他们以前可能没有考虑过的叙事选择，并邀请他们以不同的方式叙述他们的生活。因此，个人的生活
stories aren't just co-narrated, so are cultural narratives. And so we can intervene in cultural narratives by narrating our own experience of our cultural context differently. Jonathan Adler is a psychologist at Olin College. Jonathan, thank you so much for joining me again today on Hidden Brain. Totally my pleasure. Thank you. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Before we go today, we want to say thank you to Loom by Atlassian for sponsoring the
故事不仅是被共同叙述的，文化叙事也是如此。因此，我们可以通过以不同方式叙述我们对文化背景的个人体验来干预文化叙事。乔纳森·阿德勒是欧林学院的一位心理学家。乔纳森，非常感谢你今天再次来到《隐藏的大脑》。这完全是我的荣幸。谢谢你。《隐藏的大脑》由隐藏大脑传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·帕尔、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·克雷尔、莱恩·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德里克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。在今天的节目结束前，我们要感谢Atlassian旗下的Loom赞助了
Hidden Brain 2025 Perceptions Tour. While on tour, we asked members of the audience to tell us about some of the best advice they ever received. Here's one piece of wisdom shared during our stop in Mesa, Arizona. My name is Nick. The advice I have begins with a statement that you probably may have heard. We judge others by their actions and we judge ourselves by our intentions. And I've heard that a lot of times throughout my life by many different people.
《隐藏的大脑》2025年感知之旅。在巡演期间，我们请听众分享了他们曾经收听过的最好的一些建议。以下是我们在亚利桑那州梅萨市停留期间分享的一段智慧。我叫尼克。我的建议始于一句话，你可能已经听过了。我们根据他人的行为来判断他人，而根据我们的意图来判断自己。我在生活中从许多不同的人那里听到过很多次这句话。
but something I didn't understand was what that really, what to do with that information. Me and my friend talked about it for a long time, and we came to the conclusion that you must flip those two to really be able to understand others and have empathy for others. You must judge yourself by your actions. You can see yourself from their perspective, and you must judge them from their intentions. Thank you. Thank you. Thanks to Nick for sharing that advice, and thanks again to Loom for sponsoring the 2025
但我一直不理解的是这究竟意味着什么，该如何利用这些信息。我和我的朋友讨论了很长时间，我们得出的结论是，你必须将这两者颠倒过来，才能真正理解他人并对他人产生同理心。你必须根据自己的行为来审视自己，你可以从他们的视角来看待自己，而你必须根据他们的意图来判断他们。谢谢。谢谢。感谢尼克分享这个建议，也再次感谢Loom赞助2025
Perceptions Tour. Loom is AI-powered video communication that moves teams forward, whether you're sharing feedback, obtaining approvals, or setting context. It removes the friction by making it easy to share and collaborate on work without having to be in the same room or time zone. Try Loom today at loom.com. That's L-O-O-O-M.com. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
Perceptions Tour。Loom 是一个由人工智能驱动的视频沟通平台，能够推动团队向前发展，无论您是在分享反馈、获取审批还是设定背景。它通过让工作分享和协作变得轻松，消除了身处同一房间或时区的阻碍。立即访问 loom.com 体验 Loom。即 L-O-O-O-M.com。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。